le bilan est très lourd plus de 11 300
morts à l'heure où l'on se parle et
juste après cette déclaration solennelle
du président du Sénat et bien c'est
Elisabeth borne la première ministre qui
devrait sur ce thème dire quelques mots
ensuite commencera alors la séance
habituelle des mercredis des questions
au gouvernement on attend deux grands
enfants tout d'abord des questions sur
les concessions autoroutières ce sont
les deux premières questions à 15h ainsi
qu'ensuite des questions sur la réforme
des retraites alors que le silence se
fait dans l'hémicycle et que je vous le
disais la séance va s'ouvrir par et bien
une déclaration du président du Sénat
suite au terrible tremblement de terre
qui ont touché la Turquie et la Syrie et
que donc Élisabeth borne qui est
installé un derrière moi dans
l'hémicycle va également prendre la
parole sur ce sujet donc des
tremblements de terre qui ont touché ces
deux pays dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
lundi
au premier jour du jour
plusieurs tremblements de terre ont
frappé le sud-est de la Turquie et de la
Syrie voisine
ils ont été suivis de nombreuses et très
violentes
alors que le bilan humain de cette
catastrophe
s'alourdit le jour en jour
je souhaitais que nos pensées aille aux
victimes et à leurs proches ainsi qu'aux
équipes mobilisées pour leur porter
secours
nous serons attentifs est-ce que tous
les secours nécessaires parviennent aux
populations touchées ou qu'elles se
trouvent et sans autre critère
que ceux de l'urgence
et que la France
madame la Première ministre apportera
toute sa contribution
à l'aide internationale déployée
je suis certain au nom du Sénat tout
entier
je voulais
exprimer notre solidarité
au peuple turc et syrien et les assurés
de notre soutien
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs au nom du
gouvernement je veux à mon tour redire
toute notre solidarité au peuple turc et
syrien dès lundi le président de la
République a annoncé la mobilisation de
notre pays est proposée une aide
d'urgence des sapeurs-pompiers des
sapeurs sauveteurs et des personnels du
centre de crise et de soutien sont
arrivés sur place il contribue aux
recherches sur le terrain pour aider les
blessés nous avons également proposé
l'envoi d'un hôpital de campagne de la
sécurité civile mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la France est aux côtés
des peuples turcs et syriens dans cette
épreuve je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la science est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
sur notre site internet
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges ces valeurs essentielles qui
sont là respect valeur essentiel qui est
le respect des uns et des autres mais
valeurs aussi importantes que le respect
du temps de parole la parole est
maintenant au président Vincent Delahaye
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste il
avait la parole
[Applaudissements]
et merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres
le groupe Union centriste s'associe tout
naturellement à la solidarité vis-à-vis
du peuple turc et du peuple syrien et
bien sûr apporte tout son soutien à nos
compatriotes qui sont partis sur place
pour les secours ma question a très aux
concession d'autoroute notre commission
d'enquête au Sénat
dont je salue les membres ici présents
et notamment ceux du non centriste
Anne-Catherine Loisier et Arnaud de
belnay à qui s'associe bien sûr à ma
question a mis en lumière une
surentabilité de plus de 30 milliards
d'euros d'ici la fin des contrats cette
surentabilité a été confirmée par le
rapport de l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui a été révélée par Le Canard
Enchaîné notre commission
a mis fin à un cirque infernal de
progression de ces contrats contre des
travaux elle a également proposé de se
mettre d'accord sur l'équilibre
économique et financier de ces contrats
monsieur le ministre Clément bonne m'a
en novembre dernier qu'un groupe de
travail serait mis en place à ce sujet
en début d'année qu'en pensez-vous le
mettre en place monsieur le ministre et
le premier février il y a une
augmentation de 4,75% des tarifs cette
augmentation permet aux sociétés
d'autoroute de réaliser un profil
supplémentaire de 300 millions par an
d'ici la fin des contrats j'aimerais
savoir
si les efforts qui ont été demandés à
Vinci
représentent cette somme là où quel
pourcentage de cette somme là est
représenté et pourquoi n'avons-nous rien
demandé à Eiffage
pour vous répondre
la parole économique de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Christophe Béchu il
avait la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de
d'abord je voudrais saluer la qualité de
ce rapport sénatorial qui date qui date
de septembre 2020 qui a gardé beaucoup
de son actualité vous avez cité ce
rapport de l'IGF dans certains passages
ont été rendus publics par Le Canard
Enchaîné rapport qui a été transmis au
président des commissions des finances
de l'Assemblée et du Sénat
je vous invite aussi et je sais que vous
l'avez certainement fait compte tenu de
votre maîtrise sur le sujet à regarder
le rapport de la RT qui est sorti il y a
quelques jours et dont les conclusions
diffèrent un peu passent sur le fait
qu'il y a une rentabilité importante
mais qui n'arrive pas au même chiffre au
même calcul et qu'invite un minimum de
prudence en particulier parce que
l'impact du covid n'a pas été à ce stade
intégré dans ce qui était l'été rit pour
la suite je me permets de vous indiquer
puisque vous avez cité cette
augmentation du premier février qui
était prévue dans les contrats que à
cette occasion une des préconisations de
votre apport sur le fait de pouvoir
diminuer les péages pour les véhicules
propres s'appliquent avec une baisse de
5% et non pas une hausse pour les
véhicules électriques et vous pouvez je
pense y voir une forme d'hommage à un
des sujets sur lesquels vous avez
travaillé sur lequel vous aviez émis des
préconisations plus largement le 13
janvier dernier nous avons remporté une
bataille importante devant le tribunal
administratif dans le cadre de
l'augmentation des impôts que nous
souhaitons sur les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute là aussi
dans la de votre apport les sociétés
concessionnelles d'autoroute ont
jusqu'au 13 mars pour faire appel de
cette alourdissement de leur fiscalité
mais il va de soi que nous suivons
évidemment ce contentieux nous
continuons de réfléchir au meilleur
manières de les associer compte tenu des
rentabilités qui sont projetées d'ici la
fin des concessions un effort contenu
des besoins globaux que nous avons en
termes de décarbonation vous avez à la
fois pointé dans votre rapport le fait
qu'il y avait une meilleure contribution
à mettre en place et que la
renationalisation n'était pas la
solution compte tenu des montants en jeu
je voudrais saluer cette analyse et vous
dire évidemment la volonté que nous
avons travaillé avec vous quand cette
phase contentieuse sera terminée à
regarder ensemble vers la suite et vers
la fin de concession et sur l'équilibre
restant
merci
monsieur le Président de la
merci monsieur le ministre c'est vrai
que vous m'apprenez pas à grand chose
dans votre réponse et malheureusement
vous ne répondez pas à ma question je
voulais savoir quand on allait pouvoir
travailler ensemble sur l'équilibre
économique et financier des contrats
vous me dites pas le Clément bon de
m'avait dit en début d'année je ne sais
pas et sur l'effort qui a été demandé à
Vinci et celui qui n'a pas été demandé à
Eiffage on ne sait pas ce qu'il
représente c'est toujours pareil il y a
pas de transparence sur ce sujet nous on
demande de la transparence et la défense
de l'intérêt général et nous sommes ici
au Sénat 40 cette défense de l'intérêt
général et nous continuerons à
travailler sur ce sujet merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Noëlle linman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste il avait la parole oui
monsieur le mesdames messieurs les
ministres à notre tour le groupe CRCE
nous apportons évidemment toute notre
soutien au peuple
turc syrien
monsieur le ministre les tarifs
autoroutiers viennent d'augmenter de 4,7
%. alors que les profils des
concessionnaires explosent depuis la
privatisation c'est le même constat
profitez mesurer pH toujours plus cher
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est que
désormais au sein même de Bercy ce
constat interroge et même d'une certaine
façon scandalise la presse est fait
l'écho du rapport de 2021 très
instructif de l'Inspection des finances
il explique que ces entreprises ont une
rentabilité très supérieure à celle
attendue qu'elle va contre le principe
de rémunération raisonnable au point de
demander à l'État de réagir notamment
dénonçant les conventions et il estime
avoir le support juridique nécessaire
les sommes en cause permettrait une
réduction de près de 60% des péages et
un prélèvement allant jusqu'à
55,4 milliards pour l'État une paille
l'Autorité de régulation
des Transports a beaucoup testé la
surentabilité elle constate néanmoins
une hausse des bénéfices de 47% en 2021
déjà nous avions avec leur rapport
sénatorial pointé cette rentabilité hors
norme l'État ne peut plus faire
l'autruche et comme chaque fois quand
des parlementaires demandent des comptes
ou comme le propose notre groupe nous
demandons la rue nationalisation
monsieur le ministre comment justifier
vous que l'État ne fasse pas tout pour
baisser les péages ne mettent pas fin
aux concessions actuelles et vous prêt à
travailler avec le Parlement à
l'hypothèse d'une rue nationalisation
pour vous répondre la parole était au
ministre de la transition écologique la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
pour finir de répondre au président de
la m et c'est aussi la fin de votre
propre question le gouvernement est prêt
effectivement au-delà du mois de mars je
pensais avoir été plus clair quand on
aura clos cette phase à faire en sorte
qu'on puisse se pencher sur la suite et
sur l'avenir des concessions et la façon
dont il convient d'ores et déjà d'en
préparer la sortie
à la question très précise est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à travailler à la
perspective de la rationalisation des
autoroutes ma réponse est la même que
celle que la Haute Assemblée a faite à
la proposition de loi qui a été portée
par votre groupe c'est non
la rustine nationalisation
la renationalisation c'est 50 milliards
d'euros c'est 50 milliards d'euros nous
avons la conviction que nous devons les
utiliser
au service non pas de la route mais de
la décarbonation des transports des
reports fluviaux et en particulier des
investissements dans le ferroviaire
dépenser de l'argent pour racheter les
autoroutes ça irait contre la transition
écologique et ça se traduirait à la fin
par une mauvaise allocation des
ressources publiques
je vous signale d'ailleurs que c'est
très exactement la conclusion du fameux
réparti du rapport sénatorial du
président de La Haye qui insiste puisque
vous l'avez cité sur le fait qu'il
s'agirait d'une fausse bonne idée et
d'une mauvaise piste le sujet il est
donc de regarder comment nous augmentons
la contribution des autoroutes c'est
encore une fois ce qui a été fait dans
le cadre de la loi de finance 2020 avec
l'indexation de la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire avec la victoire juridique
que nous avons enregistrée au début du
mois de janvier et avec les réflexions
que nous continuons avec les réflexions
que nous continuons à déployer avec le
même objectif de financer via la route
une partie du rapport modal d'autant
qu'il y a d'autres sujets devant nous
autour de la décarbonation y compris de
la route qui nécessitera des engagements
et qui nécessitent d'être intégrés dans
l'équilibre généraux des contrats et des
concessions
merci
la parole est maintenant président Alain
Richard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances
vous êtes et nous sommes face à un grand
défi pour la France
accéléré l'innovation et la
détermination de nos industries
au même moment la loi une fashion Act
aux États-Unis a commencé à s'appliquer
en faveur certes des industries des
carbonées mais avec un double risque
les subventions massives attribuées de
façon discriminatoire contre les
vendeurs européens et une attraction
potentielle des investisseurs européens
sur le marché des États-Unis sur le
territoire des États-Unis vous revenez
d'une visite de dialogues aux États-Unis
en compagnie de votre collègue allemand
monsieur abbek pour rétablir une
concurrence normale et le travail se
poursuit je pense se conclut à Bruxelles
entre la Commission et les gouvernements
pour enclencher un plan européen de
soutien à nos industries en mutation
vers le zéro carbone
quel bilan tirez-vous de la discussion
avec les autorités Washington sur ce
sujet et quel aboutissement pensez-vous
obtenir très prochainement pour un
réarmement industriel européen en
traitant de façon dynamique les deux
sujets bien connus entre Européens des
règles de concurrence interne et des
aides d'État il y a un sérieux effort de
convergence entre européen a finir d'ici
le sommet prévu demain et après-demain
monsieur le ministre pour vous répondre
la parole est communiste de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique Monsieur le
Maire merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur à la Richard je
tire trois conclusions
simple de se déplacement à Washington la
première conclusion ça nous surprendra
pas c'est l'efficacité du couple
franco-allemand et l'alignement entre
l'Allemagne et la France sur la
nécessité d'accélérer nos
investissements en matière de
décarbonation industrielle et
d'industrie verte de ce point de vue le
signal que nous avons envoyé qu'on
homologue allemand robertabeck est un
signal de coopération étroite à la suite
du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemands tenu par le Président
de la République et le chancelier Olaf
schottes le deuxième message c'est que
nos alliés américains sont prêts à les
ouvertures et qu'ils en ont fait pendant
notre déplacement ils sont prêts des
ouvertures pour inclure un certain
nombre de biens industriels européens
les voitures électriques dans le cadre
du leasing et des véhicules commerciaux
les batteries électriques et les
composantes de batterie électrique la
corne n'est pas encore définitive mais
nous poussons avec la Commission
européenne pour obtenir un accord
chaussée produit ils sont prêts en
deuxième lieu afin de transparence
totale sur le montant des subventions et
ce qui est indispensable pour garantir
une concurrence équitable et ils sont
prêts enfin à ce que nous préservions
nos investissements stratégiques mais la
troisième conclusion la plus importante
c'est que l'Europe doit aller au bout de
la Révolution stratégique qui a été
portée par le Président de la République
porté par la France en vue d'être
totalement indépendant et souverain nous
avons aujourd'hui les propositions de la
Commission européenne qui vont dans le
bon sens simplification des aides
possibilités de mettre en place des
crédits d'impôts pour soutenir
l'industrie verte soutenir la production
d'hydrogène soutenir la production de
batterie électrique ou de
semi-conducteurs sur notre territoire
nous avons une clause d'alignement qui
doit nous permettre de rivaliser à armes
égales avec les États-Unis bien je
souhaite qu'au prochain Conseil européen
c'est ce que portera le président de la
République nous puissions mettre en
œuvre sans délai le projet de la
Commission européenne de façon que nous
puissions accélérer la
réindustrialisation de l'Europe et la
décarbonation de notre industrie il en
va de notre souveraineté de notre
indépendance il y a encore effectivement
des divergences de vues entre européen
il faut les surmonter c'est la condition
pour que l'Europe continue à jouer les
premiers rôles en matière industrielle
au 21e siècle merci monsieur le
président Richard
[Applaudissements]
de la parole de notre collègienne
chanterelle pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
madame la Première ministre elle
s'appelle Véronique elle a 53 ans je
l'ai rencontré hier lors de la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites à Paris après deux années
d'apprentissage en charcuterie Véronique
a commencé à travailler à l'âge de 16
ans pendant de longues années à la
trimestre sur les marchés dans le froid
de l'hiver parfois jusqu'à moins 12 à
soulever de lourdes charges si bien qu'à
seulement 33 ans la dû se faire opérer
de la colonne vertébrale malgré cette
vie de labeur malgré la pénibilité de
son travail avec les arrêts maladie et
les périodes de chômage Véronique ne
pourra partir à la retraite qu'après
avoir cotisé 44 années c'est plus que
vous et moi qui ne subissons pas la
pénibilité physique de son travail
où est la justice votre réforme des
retraites n'en est pas une c'est un
exercice de rééquilibrage financier
après que vous ayez grevé le budget de
l'État par des cadeaux fiscaux aux
grandes entreprises suppression de l'ISF
suppression de la CVAE de la flat tax et
ses cadeaux aux grandes entreprises
c'est à toutes les véroniques de France
que vous en faites payer la facture
aujourd'hui même on apprend que
l'entreprise totale a fait des profits
records en 2022
19,1 milliard d'euros c'est plus que les
13,5 milliards de déficits que veut
prévoyez pour le système de retraite à
l'horizon 2030 alors madame la Première
ministre contre allez vous taxer c'est
super profits quant allez vous écouter
les centaines de milliers de Françaises
et de Français qui étaient hier dans la
rue pour dire non à la retraite à 64 ans
quant allez vous retirer ce projet
injuste et brutal
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et à
Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question Véronique a 53 ans vous l'avez
dit vous m'avez dit qu'elle avait
commencé à l'âge de 16 ans donc en
fonction de si elle a commencé un peu
avant 16 ans ou à l'âge de 16 ans vous
pouvez déjà lui dire qu'elle ne partira
pas à ni à 64 ans ni même à 62 ans
monsieur le sénateur mais au plus tard à
60 ans voir si elle a commencé un peu
plus tôt 58 ans et vous verrez je le
sénateur que par rapport à la situation
actuelle il est même pas impossible que
sa situation personnelle s'en trouve
améliorée sur le sénateur vous parlez de
vous parler de Véronique comme étant
exposé des températures extrêmes vous la
décrivez comme étant exposée au port de
charge très lourdes bref vous portez là
un certain nombre de critères de
pénibilité et dans le projet de loi que
vous aurez bientôt à examiné et je
l'espère voter vous verrez qu'en matière
de pénibilité ce projet de et porteur
d'avancer social comme il y en avait pas
eu lors des précédents projets de loi y
compris celui que j'ai été amené à voter
lorsque j'étais député socialiste et
qu'à l'époque la gauche de gouv
ernement fondamentaux qui étaient les
siens à savoir être capable de prendre
des décisions même difficiles quand il
fallait conforter notre modèle social à
savoir être capable de prendre des
décisions favorables à l'emploi dans
notre pays cette gauche que j'ai connu
et que j'ai quitté et je n'en ai pas de
regret aujourd'hui c'était une gauche
qui était capable de s'enthousiasmer
lorsque des entreprises créent de la
richesse et de l'emploi dans le pays
nous fait nous célébrions l'idée qu'un
jour nous puissions inverser la cour du
chômage je conçois monsieur le sénateur
que il avait fallu attendre 2017 pour
que cette fameuse courbe s'inverse cela
peut peut-être vous faire de la peine à
titre personnel mais comme vous servez
j'en suis sur l'intérêt général et
l'intérêt collectif vous devriez avec
nous avec notre majorité vous en réjouir
enfin monsieur le sénateur ne me dites
pas que vous confondez sciemment le
bénéfice mondial d'un groupe
international avec le financement d'une
caisse des retraites déficitaires du
fait de la démographie je ne crois pas
une seconde vous ne serez pas avaler les
lanternes vous savez très bien que vous
parlez vous mélangez là même pas les les
carottes et les pommes de terre vous
êtes en train de faire un le groupe
Total fait 20 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices dans le monde il en fait 500
millions il en fait 500 millions
sont prélevés par la taxe ce qui veut
dire qu'il reste 350 millions qui fasse
un effort pour le prix du carburant pour
les Français et ce sera ça ira dans le
bon sens je vous remercie
je suis en train
alors Monsieur monsieur ministre on n'a
pas de leçon à recevoir d'une personne
qui a envoyé elle-même voté pour Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2007 et qui plus est je tiens
à rappeler que la première mesure qu'a
pris Monsieur Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il
a été élu président cette supprimer des
critères de pénibilité dans pas de leçon
à recevoir de votre part là-dessus par
contre plutôt que tu as acheté la vie
des gens vous ayez le courage de revenir
sur les exonérations de cotisation
employeur qui sont inefficacées contre
eux contraintes les entreprises à
améliorer leur taux d'emploi justement
des sonneurs et surtout taxer c'est
super profits accéléré et on pourra
financer ses retraites
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre après
l'adoption définitive hier du projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable je
souhaite vous alerter une nouvelle fois
sur dysfonctionnement de certains
dispositifs de transition écologique une
nouvelle fois quand j'avais déjà
interpellé le Gouvernement sur ce sujet
en novembre dernier certes chaque
collectivité entreprise citoyens et
acteurs du changement climatique mais
l'État par sa puissance d'impulsion et
d'action un rôle primordial à jouer
aussi il est d'autant plus dommageable
de constater que dysfonctionnement
majeur subsiste notamment dans
l'application du dispositif ma prime
rénov
je ne compte plus les alertes reçues à
ce sujet et je sais qu'il en est de même
pour bon nombre de mes collègues de la
part des particuliers des artisans mais
aussi des mers qu'il faut remonter les
inquiétudes de leurs administrer en
cause la complexité du dispositif et du
site Internet y compris pour des
personnes qui sont à l'aise avec l'outil
informatique
imaginez donc les conséquences pour les
14 millions de Français qui souffrent
d'électronisme
les délais qui peuvent atteindre
plusieurs mois pour recevoir une
subvention parfois très en deçà de ce
qui avait été annoncé on a tous été
sensibilisés par des particuliers qui
avaient reçu des sommes bien inférieures
à celles promises et ont ainsi été dans
l'obligation d'emprunter pour pallier la
différence
parfois les entreprises attendent le
versement de la prime pour faire payer
le client ce qui les met elles aussi
dans une situation délicate la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment
indiquent même que certaines entreprises
se trouvent confrontées à des
négociations difficiles avec les banques
voire à des licenciements
or sans ces entreprises l'ambition du
gouvernement en matière de transition
énergétique et veine aussi j'aimerais
connaître les actions engagées pour
améliorer le dispositifs et le rendre
enfin pleinement opérationnel
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique
monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold j'associe à la réponse que
je m'apprête à vous faire les deux
autres membres du gouvernement avec
lequel nous travaillons étroitement sur
ce dossier Agnès et Olivier Klein
25000 dossiers en moyenne sont traités
chaque semaine par la NA et depuis le
lancement de ma prime rénove c'est plus
d'un million et demi de dossiers
d'accompagnement qui ont été conduits
avec
évidemment compte tenu de la masse de
dossiers dont nous parlons à la fois des
axes d'amélioration et je vais
évidemment vous répondre sur ce sujet
mais je tiens à le dire beaucoup de
trains qui arrivent à l'heure et dont on
entend peu parler y compris parce que
quand la Défenseur des droits s'est
penché sur le sujet elle a pointé le
fait qu'il y avait environ 2% des
dossiers qui posaient problème il nous
arrive d'avoir parfois des dispositifs
publics sur le plan national ou local
pour lequel nous avons des pourcentages
plus élevés de difficultés néanmoins on
a bien deux enjeux comme on rend le
dispositif plus fluide et comment on le
rend plus efficace plusieurs pistes
d'abord par rapport à l'efficacité
climatique du dispositif et le niveau de
performance et je vous indique qu'à
compter du premier septembre de cette
année il y aura la mise en place de mon
accompagnateur Renov qui devrait aussi
permettre de faciliter le dispositif
avec la volonté d'être sur un rire sa
charge de 0 pour les Français les plus
modestes c'est à dire très clairement
sur cette partie accompagnement une
partie de ceux que vous décrivez comme
étant ceux qui sont frappés
d'ylectronisme dans une partie des cas
et ça ce sera un élément de réponse
concret en parallèle sur le suivi sur le
durée de traitement il nous faut à la
fois concilier les conclusions d'un
rapport de lutte contre la fraude pour
éviter qu'une simplification extrême du
dispositif se traduisent par des risques
d'effets de bord que personne ici ne
pourrait souhaiter et dans le même temps
par le fait qu'on puisse pleinement
associer vous avez raison de le faire
les artisans pour qu'ils soient
pleinement acteurs du dispositif ce qui
suppose de raccourcir ces fameux délais
les délais moyens ils sont de 5 semaines
quand on les regarde deux semaines pour
la demande de subvention trois semaines
pour obtenir le paiement notre sujet
c'est donc de pouvoir traiter ce qui
s'écarte de ces deux bornes de temps qui
sont je vous rappelle la durée moyenne
merci beaucoup monsieur gold
merci Monsieur ministre pour ces pistes
d'amélioration mais je vous assure que
c'est vraiment une problématique pour
certains de nos concitoyens et
malheureusement souvent pour les plus
fragiles d'entre nous
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre lors de ses vœux en
2021 le président de la République louer
la première la deuxième et la troisième
ligne qui ont tenu notre pays durant la
pandémie parmi ces engagés ces
solidaires se cachent votre sœur votre
voisin vos amis des milliers d'anonymes
nous disaient-ils Marie infirmière foi
d'animateur Rosalie vendeuse Thibault
agent d'entretien Florence auxiliaire de
vie ces héros de notre République était
hier dans la rue et ils y seront samedi
et les jours suivants et il ne lâcheront
pas il ne lâcheront pas parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas votre acharnement à leur
prendre deux années de vie il ne
lâcheront pas qu'un ne comprennent pas
vos contradictions il ne lâcheront pas
car il ne comprennent pas le sens de
votre obstination et je l'avoue madame
la Première ministre je ne vous
comprends pas non plus rien de tout cela
ne vous ressemble vous nous le disiez
lors de votre déclaration de politique
générale les Français ont élu peut
sembler sans majorité absolue il nous
invite à des pratiques nouvelles à un
dialogue soutenu et à la recherche
active de compromis les pratiques
nouvelles le 47 1 le dialogue le 49-3
les compromis non négociables déni
mépris madame le Premier ministre vous
savez qu'on ne gouverne pas contre le
peuple cessez d'appliquer une consigne
que vous savez absurde cessez de vouloir
passer en force cessez d'ignorer les
syndicats les parlementaires et le
peuple cesser d'ignorer une société qui
change Marie Fouad Rosalie sont fatigués
mais il ne lâcheront pas il ne lâcheront
pas parce que leur combat est juste et
vous le savez une seule question les
taraudes quand quand allez-vous retirer
ce projet de loi aussi
inutile qu'un juste
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre vous avez la
parole madame la Première ministre merci
Monsieur Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le Président
Guillaume Gontard une fois de plus vous
avez multiplié les phrases définitives
et les caricatures alors une fois de
plus dans le même esprit de
responsabilité je veux vous rappeler les
faits
l'effet c'est que le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent et qui cotisent diminue
par rapport au nombre de retraités et si
nous ne faisons rien les déficits vont
se creuser
menaçant la pérennité de notre système
de retraite par répartition donc la
question qui se pose au travers de cette
réforme c'est la suivante voulons-nous
ou non préserver notre système de
retraite par répartition
pour y parvenir c'est vrai nous
demandons un effort aux Français c'est
le seul chemin pour assurer l'équilibre
de nos retraites et ce chemin le Sénat
ne le découvre pas il y a de réelles
convergences entre notre projet et les
travaux de votre assemblée comme en
témoigne votre adoption depuis plusieurs
années d'un amendement repoussant l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
mais monsieur le Président Gontard je
mesure sûr parfaitement ce que
travaillait plus longtemps représente
pour beaucoup de Français c'est pour ça
que nous avons mené des semaines de
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales avec les
groupes parlementaires et je le redis
dans notre projet 4 français sur 10 ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt ce qui
exerce des métiers pénibles n'auront pas
à travailler jusqu'à 64 ans alors je
n'ai pas de doute que Fouad marie et
Rosalie font partie de ces Français qui
n'auront pas à travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
et que proposez-vous que proposez-vous à
ces Français monsieur le Président
Gontard une belle drastique des pensions
le fruit d'une vie de travail ou alors
une augmentation des impôts et des
cotisations ce qui conduit
inéluctablement à une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et à une hausse du chômage alors
monsieur le Président comptin vous vous
trompez de cible car sans cette réforme
les plus riches auront toujours une
retraite en revanche pour les classes
moyennes pour les plus modestes ce sera
plus de chômage et moins de pouvoir
d'achat ce que nous proposons c'est le
plein emploi et de meilleures retraites
alors monsieur le Président Gontard je
l'ai dit et je le répète notre projet
n'est pas figé il a déjà évolué grâce au
concertations avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales avec les
groupes parlementaires il évoluera et
s'enrichira grâce au débat parlementaire
alors je sais que la dirigeante de votre
partie a appelé à faire du Parlement une
ZAD mais j'ai confiance dans la
responsabilité de chacun pour offrir aux
Français un débat de bonne tenue un
débat des idées et un débat respectueux
je ne doute pas que le Sénat il sera
particulièrement attentif je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le président Gautard madame la
Première ministre d'abord ce sont nos
retraites qui sont une zone à défendre
oui il y a des solutions oui il y a
d'autres solutions il suffit d'écouter
il suffit d'écouter les syndicats il
suffit d'écouter les parlementaires il
suffit de regarder de nous dites pas de
grâce aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent dans notre pays
c'est oui on peut taxer le capital oui
on peut taxer les dividendes oui il y a
d'autres possibilités
la parole est à notre collègue Joël
guerriot pour le gros plaisirs
Républiques et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'éducation
nationale vient d'informer de nombreux
maires ruraux de projets de fermeture
sans qu'ils aient été préalablement
consultés à titre d'exemple on
Loire-Atlantique 29 communes rurales ont
une épée de Damoclès au-dessus du toit
de leur école
ainsi les écoles rurales sont le théâtre
d'un drame qui se joue année après année
les fermetures de classe pénalisent les
familles obligées de réaliser de plus
longs trajets elle prive les petites
communes d'un élément central de leur
vitalité et bien sûr de leur
attractivité le président de la
République avait assuré en 2019
qu'aucune classe ne fermerait sans
l'accord du maire de la commune
récemment votre ministère s'est engagé à
mieux prendre en compte les contraintes
territoriales la méthode actuelle de
gestion de la carte scolaire n'est pas
adaptée aux réalités du monde rural la
décision d'ouverture et de fermeture de
classe n'est-elle pas prise chaque année
un peu trop tôt pour la rentrée suivante
il est regrettable de ne pas se projeter
à moyen terme alors que de petites
communes engagent de lourds
investissements financiers pour mettre
aux normes des locaux scolaires les élus
navigatues avec le sentiment que le
nombre de professeurs disponibles joue
le rôle de variable d'ajustement enfin
le système actuel patiente des faits de
seuil il suffit d'un seul élève manquant
pour fermer une classe mais il en faut
beaucoup plus pour l'ouvrir au-delà
d'une logique comment comptable liée à
la baisse démocratique nos petites
collectivités ont besoin de leurs écoles
dès lors monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous aider nos communes rurales
en prenant en considération le point de
vue des mers ruraux merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse que papa Ndiaye
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur guerriot votre question
s'inscrit dans un contexte démographique
général celui de la baisse
accélérée des effectifs scolaires moins
500 000 élèves dans les 5 années à venir
entre 90 et 100 000 en moins d'ici à la
rentrée 2023 cette situation est certes
regrettable mais elle conduit en effet à
des ajustements c'est le travail
complexe qui est actuellement mené et
qui aboutira en août à une stabilisation
de la carte scolaire pour la rentrée
2023 notre ligne directrice elle est
très simple nous nous adaptons aux
réalités démographiques nationales
régionales et locale tout en tenant
particulièrement compte de la situation
des territoires ruraux dans votre
département de Loire-Atlantique entre
les la crise scolaire 2017 et 2022 se
sont près de 2500 élèves en moins que
l'on a compté pour parallèlement la
création de 326 postes d'enseignement
d'ici à 2023 on va compter en
Loire-Atlantique 743 élèves en moins or
dans la répartition des moyens qui est
faite en Loire-Atlantique les
territoires ruraux font l'objet d'une
attention soutenue sur les 33 communes
situées dans les 33 écoles pardon situé
dans les communes les plus rurales les
plus éloignés nous avons un nombre moyen
d'élèves par classe qui est de 19 qui
est donc inférieur à la moyenne du
département qui est de 22,5 à ce stade
les 33 communes rurales sont concernées
par 9 fermetures mais également
parallèlement 4 ouvertures je termine en
disant que ce projet de carte scolaire
qui sera arrêtée à la rentrée scolaire
fait l'objet d'ajustement ces
ajustements ne sont pas clos nous
faisons une première étape en février
une deuxième étape en juin et une
troisième étape en août et je suis à
votre disposition pour en reparler
monsieur guériot
merci Monsieur simplement votre
attention sur le fait que d'un côté il y
a logique à moyen terme qu'elle
investissement fait par les communes
rurales sur des petites témoignages
financiers très limités pour pouvoir
rénover agrandir voire sécuriser leurs
écoles et de l'autre côté une logique
annuelle qui consiste à faire un plan
d'effectif qui peut amener à une
fermeture de classe alors que l'année
suivante et bien il faudrait la réouvrir
mais sauf que pour la réouvrir il faut
beaucoup plus de monde que dans le cas
de la fermeture voilà le point central
de cette préoccupation et je vous
remercie de bien vouloir entendre les
mers ruraux qui sont très inquiets pour
cela
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le Président d'abord au
nom du président Bruno retailleux de
l'ensemble de notre groupe je veux
exprimer de nouveau ici notre solidarité
pleine et entière au peuple turc et
syrien et nous exprimons également notre
reconnaissance au secouriste français
partie en soutien c'est bien sûr notre
devoir mais c'est aussi madame la
Première ministre notre heure
Mesdames et Messieurs les
ministres route et des grands objectifs
à atteindre pour vous monsieur Bruno Le
Maire la réindustrialisation et de
Belgica Factory pour vous monsieur le
ministre Marc féno la souveraineté
alimentaire et donc la sauvegarde de
notaire agricoles pour vous monsieur le
ministre Clément bonne des nouvelles
lignes à grande vitesse des pistes
cyclables Canales et d'autres pour vous
Madame la Ministre Bérengère Couillard
la sauvegarde de la biodiversité et donc
naturellement la protection des espaces
naturels pour vous monsieur Klein les 13
ambitieux 400 000 logements
supplémentaires par an pour vous Madame
la Ministre Agnès panier rue naché
l’accélération des installations
d'énergie renouvelables et de centrales
nucléaires pour vous monsieur le garde
des sceaux la construction nouvelle
prison et c'est très bien et enfin pour
vous monsieur le ministre Béchu le
challenge lui répondre aux conclusions
de la modérément inspirée convention
citoyenne et l'atteinte du fameux zéro
artificialisation nette mais au fond
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
rendez vous compte qu'au bout de vos
sécurité en silo se trouve ceux qui
doivent appliquer tout cela en même
temps sur leur territoire c'est à dire
les élus locaux sur les mers il pleut
comme à Gravelotte des priorités toutes
prioritaires et des injonctions toutes
contradictions pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils deviennent sanctionnés aucune
planification territoriale ne devient
plus possible tant les priorités sont
nombreuses gouverner c'est prévoir c'est
choisir ses priorités c'est donner un
cap alors madame la Première ministre
car c'est à vous que je pose cette
question je voudrais savoir dans
l'exécution des politiques publiques
quels sont vos priorités
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe bechimilis de la
transition écologique et la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
comprends votre déception je vais
néanmoins essayer de satisfaire
aux exigences de la présidente prima qui
vient de résumer la feuille de route
qu'Elizabeth borne nous a donné et ça
aurait été contradictoire qu'elle vous
répondent en rappelant précisément la
manière dont tout ça doit se faire dans
le respect de la planification
écologique qui par ailleurs lui a été
confiée par le Président de la
République
d'abord
d'abord pour dire que dans ces
injonctions contradictoires il y a
celles qui relève du gouvernement et
puis il y a aussi ce que la
représentation nationale a pu exprimer
ici à une écrasante majorité en juin
2021 en votant cette loi climat est
résilience qui comprend ce texte sur les
héros artificialisation nette et dans
les échanges que nous avons de manière
intense il y a à la fois la réécriture
des décrets elle est tactée mais il y a
des points elle est tactée elle
interviendra au moins prochain mais il y
a des points législatifs mis d'ailleurs
en lumière par la proposition de loi
déposée par Valérie Létard et par
Jean-Baptiste blanc s'il n'y avait pas à
corriger cette loi que vous avez votée
nous ne serions pas ici en train d'avoir
cette discussion
il n'était pas prévu dans la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement un
comté à part pour les grands projets
d'envergure nationale il n'était pas
prévu dans le cadre de la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement une
garantie rurale pour faire en sorte que
précisément on puisse tenir compte des
besoins qui peuvent s'exprimer en milieu
il n'était pas prévu dans la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée par le Parlement le
solde et donc de façon très concrète
il y a des enjeux sectoriels qui ne
peuvent pas passer par la poursuite de
l'artificialisation au rythme auquel
nous le connaissons ce serait gage et
l'avenir de prétendre que au nom des
feuilles de route sectorielle nous
devrions continuer à grignoter nos
espaces agricoles ou naturels si votre
question est comment on fait pour
précisément développer des projets et
tenir compte de l'artificialisation la
réponse et l'interviendra dans quelques
jours avec le texte présenté par une
large majorité de 7 assemblée pour
engager le dialogue autour de points sur
lesquels la première ministre le 24
novembre dernier lors du congrès des
mers a déjà indiqué les points sur
lequel nous étions prêt à bouger sur
lesquels je travaille à l'heure actuelle
avec Valérie Letard et Jean-Baptiste
blanc avant ce rendez-vous dans
l'hémicycle au mois de mars
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Marc
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale
sur la suppression de centaines de
classes en milieu rural vous avez
répondu monsieur le ministre par des
chiffres diminution du nombre d'élèves
taux d'encadrement ratio et en même
temps la priorité d'améliorer les
conditions d'enseignement et
d'encadrement en même temps le candidat
est aujourd'hui président Macron déclaré
il n'y aura plus de fermeture de classe
sans Laval du maire mais Monsieur le
Ministre la réalité tout autre vous
appliquez des critères qui accélèrent la
fermeture des classes et des cols
rurales avec la suppression de 2000
postes et en même temps le soutien à la
ruralité est affiché comme une priorité
par les ministres forts et Béchu les
mers des territoires demandent une
concertation promise depuis plusieurs
mois la prise en compte de contraintes
territoriales avec la définition d'un
indice d'éloignant et la spécificité des
classes multi-âge pourquoi quand vous
poursuivez le dédoublement des classes
en zone sensible prioritaire le monde
rural doit payer le début d'une approche
comptable déséquilibrée l'école rurale
est une chance pour nos enfants car il
conjugue proximité qualité de
l'enseignement la ruralité nos petites
communes sont aussi des zones sensibles
prioritaires et doivent aussi bénéficier
du dédoublement des classes alors je
vous le demande monsieur le ministre un
moratoire sur la fermeture des classes
et école en milieu rurale
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse monsieur pavé merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Boyer
depuis la rentrée
2019 conformément à l'engagement du
président de la République
aucune fermeture d'école d'école et non
pas de classe ne peut intervenir sans
l'accord du maire ce n'est pas la même
chose dans le contexte démographique
générale en effet dans votre que j'ai
indiqué
à l'instant votre département du
Puy-de-Dôme va perdre 616 élèves à la
rentrée 2023 or si nous devions
adopter une règle comptable pour
reprendre votre expression ce serait 25
postes d'enseignants en moins que nous
compterions à la rentrée 2023 or pour le
département du Puy-de-Dôme nous retirons
9 postes d'enseignement de telle sorte
que le taux d'encadrement va s'améliorer
le rapport entre les enseignants et les
élèves va s'améliorer dans le Puy de
Dôme nous examinons très attentivement
les 491 école de votre département ce
qui nous conduit à envisager la
fermeture d'une trentaine de classes
mais l'ouverture d'une vingtaine de
classes car quand nous parlons de
suppression de classe nous parlons
également d'un solde c'est-à-dire d'une
différence entre les ouvertures et les
fermetures enfin je vous rappelle
puisque vous mentionnez à juste titre la
question de l'éloignement et vous avez
raison dans les territoires ruraux la
question de l'éloignement et tout à fait
importante nous avons créé les
territoires
éducatif ruraux il y en a un qui
fonctionne très bien justement dans le
puit de dôme qui associe collège et
école dans des dispositifs qui
permettent d'avancer sur la question de
la distance et de la distanciation
rurale nous travaillons aux modalités
d'extension des territoires éducatifs
ruraux et c'est une solution qui
correspond à une forme
parallèle si vous voulez à ce qui est
expérimenté et ce qui est mené dans les
villes de manière à faire de ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux un point
d'appui pour améliorer la situation de
nos élèves
monsieur Boyer
ce ministre vos actions amplifient la
fracture territoriale et suscite la
colère des mers et des citoyens qui
subissent déjà les déserts médicaux la
fracture numérique le zan on en a parlé
tout à l'heure la France défigurée par
les éoliennes la Poste qui envisage
bientôt une tournée des facteurs un jour
sur deux le transfert imposé de l'eau et
de l'assainissement l'accessibilité
insuffisante de nos territoires avec le
train et l'avion je ne vous parle pas de
chiffres mais je vous parle d'élèves
d'humains cesser se mépris pour les
habitants des territoires ruraux cesser
se sacrifice de la ruralité sur l'Hôtel
des quotas et des normes sinon mesdames
et messieurs les ministres les Gaulois
réfractaires risquent de se réveiller
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Michael Valley pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du Logement les nouvelles plateformes
numériques ont sur l'économie la plus
réelle des effets parfois revitalisants
mais d'autres choix ces outils se
révèlent une menace profonde pour la
cohésion républicaine et la puissance
publique doit alors reprendre la main et
fermement ainsi certaines villes
touristiques font les frais nous le
savons d'une concurrence insupportable
entre les logements classiques et les
meublés de tourisme ne serait-ce qu'en
Charente-Maritime on constate par
exemple à Oléron des abus énormes
dénoncés par les élus locaux concernant
la collecte et le reversement des taxes
de séjour ou encore à La Rochelle ou une
explosion du phénomène se produit avec
rien qu'en 2022 plus de 1700 meublés de
tourisme nouvellement déclarés qui
évacent autant de travailleurs et
d'étudiants en mal de logement La
Rochelle justement a attaqué le mal à la
racine et dès 2019 en soumettant à
autorisation préalable la mise sur le
marché de meubler tourisme grâce à un
numéro d'enregistrement unique et en
instaurant pour les personnes
un dispositif d'autorisation de
changement d'usage temporaire des locaux
destinés à l'habitation pour des
locations de courte durée mais
aujourd'hui ces mesures ne suffisent
plus et La Rochelle a voulu aller plus
loin en 2022 en élargissant son
dispositif par le changement d'usage
permanent permettant de toucher aussi
les personnes morales pour ne pas dire
les SCI en exigeant des mesures de
compensation avec la transformation d'un
local en logements à l'année pour chaque
logement de tourisme mis sur le marché
ou en favorisant la réservation des
logements de petite taille aux étudiants
ou aux jeunes actifs vivants seuls
malheureusement cette agglomération
comme d'autres se heurte un cadre légal
et réglementaire dont joue parfaitement
les utilisateurs de plateformes ainsi
qu'à l'appréciation négative par les
juridictions de la proportionnalité des
mesures mises en oeuvre pourtant avoir
un toit pour étudier travailler et
pouvoir vivre près des siens et le
premier élément d'insertion dans la
communauté nationale alors Monsieur le
Ministre quelle mesure vous engagez-vous
à proposer avec le concours de ses
collectivités guitariste et du Parlement
on ne peut plus laisser la
plateformeisation du logement miner le
pacte républicain
la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Valais
la semaine prochaine
mardi pour être précis avec Olivier
Klein et Dominique Faure ne recevrons
toutes les associations d'élus pour
discuter avec elle de décentralisation
du logement
au sens large
et pour ensemble conformément à la fois
aux souhait du président de la
République et de la première ministre
échanger aussi bien sur le fait de
savoir si les zones tendues doivent
continuer à être déterminés d'un point
de vue national par les ministères ou si
sur la base de l'expérimentation du
Pinel breton des choses de ce type
peuvent se décliner sur le territoire
pour échanger y compris sur la
rénovation et sur le fait de savoir si
davantage de proximité ne permettrait
pas parfois de faire en sorte de mieux
tenir compte de ce que peuvent être les
difficultés qui sont rencontrées mais
pour échanger aussi plus largement sur
les freins à la construction sur
l'accompagnement de celles et ceux qui
ont des difficultés pour se loger au
milieu de tout ça évidemment la question
des plateformes sera posée vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui en fonction de la façon
dont vous êtes classé les instruments
qui sont à votre main ne sont pas les
mêmes et il y a des communes
touristiques je pense à La Baule je
pense à Bayonne qui ont pris des
législations particulièrement
restrictives sur la base du droit
existant avec un succès réel et d'autres
qui cherchent le chemin
nous avons dans les outils juridiques
existants aujourd'hui beaucoup de
capacités à faire avec quelques trous
dans la raquette sans doute sur lequel
il convient d'être vigilant mais nous
pensons que c'est avec les associations
des lieux en nous rapprochant des moyens
qu'on pourrait leur donner sur le plan
local contient une réponse de
l'hétérogénéité des situations là aussi
notre conviction c'est qu'il faut qu'on
trouve un chemin qui s'appuie sur les
territoires avec eux parce que les
situations ne sont pas comparables et
vous avez cité des exemples qui sont
inspirants mais qui méritent d'être
déclinés en donnant les outils au plus
près du terrain qui permettront d'agir
c'est très exactement le sens de cette
première réunion que nous aurons avec
mes collègues ministres
la parole est à notre collègue Vincent
Segoin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les labels de qualité de la
volaille française que nous avons tous
identifié comme le label rouge ou la
mention AB vont-ils disparaître depuis
des années les filières agricoles
françaises ont œuvré pour produire des
volailles qui répondent aux normes de
production au bien-être animal et aux
attentes des consommateurs c'est énorme
identifié par un étiquetage clair et
simple ont permis à la production
française de trouver une place sur le
marché à des conditions de concurrence
équitables mais voilà que la Commission
européenne a décidé fin 2022 d'accorder
la pleine liberté à tout type d'élevage
d'utiliser des labels sans fondement et
sans aucun contrôle nous risquons ainsi
devoir apparaître des mentions
fantaisistes comme poulet de plein vent
ou poulet des champs qui tromperont
dorénavant le consommateur alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quelle stratégie comptez-vous
mettre en place pour sauver ces labels
et nos filières agricoles
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire Monsieur
marcéno Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci monsieur
le sénateur Segoin de votre question qui
me permet de clarifier et de vous
exprimer devant vous la position de la
France qui a déjà été exprimée à
plusieurs reprises par voie écrites
orales et lors de conseils européens
vous avez raison c'est une inquiétude
c'est une réforme des normes de
commercialisation qui est initié par la
Commission
et c'est soumis aux États me pourra
vivre uniquement et c'est bien ça la
difficulté ou le travail que nous avons
à faire avec la commission dès le début
de cette négociation la France a indiqué
son désaccord sur différents points en
particulier sur la révision des
dispositions relatives aux mention
valorisantes réservée facultative
c'est-à-dire aux normes de
commercialisation vous avez très bien
décrit les risques qui sont le premier
risque c'est un risque de tromperie
vis-à-vis des consommateurs c'est
d'induire et d'introduire une notion qui
soit suffisamment vague pour qu'on
puisse ne plus valoriser un certain
nombre de nos productions le deuxième
risque c'est sur nos filières en
particulier celle de plein air les
labels rouges et autres de ne pas
pouvoir les valoriser comme elles sont
valorisées en ce moment et donc j'ai
écrit au commissaire j'ai discuté avec
le commissaire nous travaillons avec la
commission pour faire en sorte que la
proposition qui sera examinée le 22
février prochain par le comité d'experts
face en sorte que nous respections ces
règles qui ont été édictées dans les
années 90 qui sont de nature à rassurer
le consommateur à lui donner une vision
claire sur ce qu'il achète et qui
permettent à nos producteurs de
valoriser leur production dans un dans
des conditions qui soient des conditions
de valorisation satisfaisantes et c'est
bien ça qui est en jeu c'est en jeu dans
votre département de l'ordre des objets
très attaché à cette filière comme dans
tous les départements où il y a de la
production de volailles nous continuons
à travailler à la fois sur ces mentions
valorisantes sur le fait qu'on puisse
les maintenir et puis de globalement sur
une filière qui est déjà vous l'avez pas
dit mais je le rappelle mais vous le
savez aussi bien que moi il y a des gens
grands risques du fait de la crise
sanitaire qu'elle traverse je pars de
l'influence à vierge et là aussi nous
sommes aux cheveux et au travail avec
ces filières pour faire en sorte que
nous trouvions des solutions de court
terme et puis de long terme avec
l'affaire du la vaccination merci
beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
Monsieur Seguin
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre n'oublions nous
multiplions toutes les occasions
possibles ici au Sénat comme hier avec
le commerce extérieur ou la ferme France
pour vous alerter sur le déclin
économique de la France par le poids des
charges et des normes vous nous répondez
que les éleveurs français doivent monter
en gamme pour trouver des marchés avec
des marges plus élevées selon les
objectifs de la stratégie farm to fork
ou Green Deal bilan dans la filière
avicole la ferme France a perdu la
bataille face aux importations pour la
restauration collective ou les plats
préparés alors il nous reste le poulet
du dimanche le labellisé si vous ne
défendez pas c'est la belle qui nous
sont chers tant pour les producteurs que
pour les consommateurs nous perdrons
cette ultime bataille nous constatons
tous les jours que les normes et les
surtranspositions s'appliquent aux
agriculteurs français et que notre
administration se développe toujours
plus pour contrôler nos productions
plutôt que des produits qui sont
importés résultat nos fermes ne sont
plus reprises par les jeunes vous vous
étiez engagés à faire respecter les
clauses miroirs nous attendons des
suites vous acceptez au contraire une
nouvelle concurrence déloyale à nos
productions et probablement au 15000
emplois ruraux affiliés et labels
monsieur le ministre la ferme France
brûle mais nous regardons ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole de notre collègue de Nice un
peu pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique elle porte sur
l'état des négociations européennes
concernant l'hydrogène bas carbone
celle-ci patine pour le moment puisque
le trilogue prévu hier pour examiner la
directive énergie renouvelable a été
annulée et reporté au 6 mars ce texte
fixe des objectifs ambitieux d'emploi de
l'hydrogène dans l'industrie ce dont on
peut se réjouir mais il prévoit que
cette hydrogène devrait être produit à
partir d'électricité renouvelable sans
dire un mot de l'électricité produite à
partir d'énergie nucléaire or
si nous ne pouvons pas utiliser nos
réacteurs nucléaires pour produire de
l'hydrogène la France va avoir beaucoup
de mal à atteindre les objectifs
européens l'Union européenne avait déjà
tenté sans succès d'exclure le nucléaire
de la taxonomie
prohibé l'hydrogène bacarbonne permet
toujours de l'attaquer indirectement
madame la ministre vous avez vivement
réagi en qualifiant cette exclusion de
climaticides et absurde nous ne pouvons
que vous en féliciter car le nucléaire
et l'énergie la moins carbonée dont nous
disposons je note par ailleurs que la
France est loin d'être le seul État
membre frustré par le contenu actuel du
texte aussi je voudrais savoir comment
se présente les négociations sur ce
sujet enfin si la France n'obtient pas
gain de cause serez-vous prête à bloquer
la directive énergie renouvelable pour
défendre notre filière nucléaire et
hydrogène je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
la parole que la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame panier
renier
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Saint-Pée je
l'affirme nettement les négociations sur
la directive énergie renouvelable red 3
ne prennent pas une tournure
satisfaisante sur la question de
l'hydrogène et je veux rappeler que
l'engagement de la France sur la
question des énergies renouvelables et
sans ambiguïté c'est le président de la
République qui a poussé le Green Deal en
décembre 2021 c'est moi qui présidais le
Conseil énergie le Conseil Environnement
qui a adopté le paquet climat européen
qui fait une large place aux énergies
renouvelables et c'est vous qui avez
adopté hier à une très large majorité un
projet d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables mais je suis d'accord avec
vous il ne faut pas se tromper de combat
notre combat c'est la décarbonation
c'est la défaussiliation et compte tenu
de l'ambition de ce combat nous devons
utiliser tous les leviers à notre
disposition tous les leviers c'est
reconnaître aujourd'hui que le nucléaire
est énergie qui émet moins de carbone
que l'énergie éolienne et que l'énergie
photovoltaïque et c'est pour ça
qu'empêcher l'utilisation du nucléaire
est effectivement je le redis une
position climatique alors vous le savez
les discussions à Bruxelles risque de
conduire à des objectifs d'énergie
renouvelables qui ne tient pas compte de
cette réalité d'État membre nous sommes
9 aujourd'hui qui ont décarboné une
partie de leur énergie grâce au
nucléaire il n'est plus question de
confondre les moyens à savoir les
énergies renouvelables avec l'objectif
final la décarbonation la
défaussénalisation nous avons signé ces
dernières semaines deux accords avec
d'une part l'Allemagne et d'autre part
l'Espagne qui reconnaissent le rôle que
peut jouer l'hydrogène nucléaire de
notre politique climatique j'attends de
ces deux partenaires qu'il respecte leur
engagement et soyez sûrs que je ne
laisserai pas adopter un texte contraire
à l'intérêt des Européens à l'intérêt
des Français à l'intérêt des les
industries européennes nous avons 8 pays
derrière nous nous avons une minorité de
blocage
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
piennois pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale chaque
nouvelle évaluation du niveau des élèves
scolarisés en France révèle un peu plus
les carences de notre système éducatif
ainsi selon une étude récente le niveau
n'est pas acquis pour 27% des élèves à
l'entrée en classe de 6e pour pour la
matière pour le français et un élève sur
trois ne maîtrise pas les fondamentaux
en mathématiques alors prenons
conscience semble-t-il un peu
tardivement de cette triste réalité vous
avez fait une annonce une énième réforme
ou plutôt une mesure head cosmétique
visant à créer une heure de renforcement
dans ces deux disciplines sans qu'on
sache d'ailleurs très bien qui sera
chargé d'effectuer ces heures de soutien
sans aucune considération sur l'école
primaire où l'on sait c'est là que se
crée les décrochages et avec comme effet
collatéral surprise la suppression de
l'enseignement de technologie alors
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous révéler
à la représentation nationale
la méthode de concertation et la
stratégie que j'imagine profonde qui
vous a qui vous ont conduit à prendre de
telles décisions
quand vous répondre la parole de
communiste d'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pied-noir vous l'avez dit les
évaluations de 6e ne sont pas
satisfaisantes en français pour un quart
des élèves en mathématiques pour un
tiers d'entre eux cela nous oblige à
réfléchir à la classe de 6e dans les
études montrent cette classe de
transition qu'elle est décisive pour
l'avenir des élèves et leur bonne
continuité scolaire à travers le collège
et au-delà mais cela ne n'est pas pris
de manière isolée nous réfléchissons sur
l'ensemble du cycle 3 et j'ai annoncé
une série de mesures pour les classes de
cours moyen première année deuxième
année et de sixième pour ceux qui
concerne les classes de cours moyen nous
mettons l'accent sur les français et les
mathématiques en particulier sur
l'écriture un rapport récent de
l'Inspection Générale a révélé que les
élèves consacrent 7% de leur temps
hebdomadaire à l'écriture et donc j'ai
parlé de la nécessité d'insister sur
l'écriture pas seulement la dictée mais
les travaux d'écriture les rédactions
c'est un terme un peu ancien mais c'est
essentiel la question des cahiers
d'écrivains bref tout ce qui fait écrire
les élèves plutôt que de remplir des
phrases à trous comme on le fait
beaucoup aujourd'hui j'insiste sur ce
point de même que l'inspection générale
de mathématiques nous a montré que le
calcul mental était tout à fait
essentiel également en cours moyen donc
nous insistons aussi sur le cours sur le
calcul mental et des circulaires ont été
envoyés à cet effet nous allons suivre
de près ce qui se fait en cours moyen
pour la classe de 6e en effet il y a une
heure de renforcement en français et en
mathématiques on travaille sur la
situation existante avec comme je l'ai
également annoncé des professeurs des
écoles suivant en cela ce qui a été fait
dans l'académie d'Amiens avec les
tremplin ce qui a donné de bons
résultats parallèlement à cela nous
rendons obligatoires le dispositif
devoir fait qui permet aux élèves
d'assurer leur travail sous la conduite
des professeurs au sein du collège vous
le voyez monsieur le sénateur c'est un
dispositif global qui s'attaque à la
question essentielle des savoirs
fondamentaux la technologie on la
renforce pour le 5 pour la 5e pour la
quatrième et pour la troisième
monsieur piennois
seul le ministre à l'épreuve de grand
oral du bac instauré par votre
prédécesseur votre prestation du jour
serait probablement sévèrement évalué
aucune thèse dans vos propos par
conséquent pas d'antithèse et encore
moins de synthèse en réalité l'éducation
nationale prend l'eau de toute femme
vous écopez la petite cuillère
bon c'est pas des foutaises et
dans une forme de d'improvisation
permanente dont les cobayes en réalité
sont les élèves eux-mêmes de leur côté
vous le savez bien les enseignants sont
lassés des annonces répétées
ministérielles qui ne remettent pas à
plat l'ensemble du système éducatif il
est grand temps de prendre conscience de
l'incurie des programmes de notre
système scolaire qui forme qui fabrique
des générations qui sont sensibilisées à
des tas d'événements à des tas d'enjeux
sociétaux tous plus importants les uns
que les autres mais qui sont incapables
de calculer un pourcentage et qui pense
qu'un alexandrin est un habitant
d'Alexandrie si vous pensez vraiment
qu'il faut changer cela proposer autre
chose que l’enfumage des mystique je
vous remercie
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence arrivée pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
merci monsieur le Président le projet
d'union sacré autour du logement entre
les associations et le gouvernement
peine à faire ses preuves dans un
interview donné au journal Libération ce
4 février monsieur le ministre vous
dénoncez lou trans des associations
comme
Utopia 56 ou la Fondation Abbé Pierre
que vous accusez de jouer avec la misère
des gens à travers des actions chocs de
sensibilisation ces associations ne se
contentent pourtant pas d'alerter elle
produisent surtout un travail de fond
chiffré et documentés et elles sont les
seules à le faire ce même 4 février plus
de 20 maires de gauche ont interpellé le
président de la République sur la
situation du mal logement et proposer
cette mesure qui répondent aux besoins
des différents publics en situation de
grande exclusion ma question est très
simple quelle réponse allez-vous leur
faire
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement Monsieur Olivier Klein
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Harry Bay
vous avez raison la question du
sans-abrise est une question qui nous
préoccupe tous et sur lequel le
gouvernement agit et agit de manière
historique je le rappelle encore hier
soir c'est plus de 200000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui était
ouverte dans ce pays ce chiffre n'avait
jamais été atteint quelle que soit les
gouvernements précédents ces 5,7
millions d'euros qui sont dépensés
chaque soir pour héberger les plus
fragiles et ce n'est que justice le
gouvernement a lancé le plan logement
d'abord 1 et ce plan logement d'abord un
à marché de manière historique là encore
440 000 personnes ont quitté la rue
l'hébergement d'urgence pour avoir à toi
d'ailleurs parmi les maires qui nous ont
interpellé dans le journal il y a
quelques jours plus de la moitié d'entre
eux sont des territoires d'accélération
du plan logement d'abord 1 et je les
réuni très régulièrement notamment pour
préparer le plan logement d'abord 2 et
je leur ai proposé de les recevoir dès
demain pour continuer à travailler avec
eux et les propositions qu'ils font sont
celles avec lequel nous avons discuté il
y a quelques jours dans la préparation
du plan logement d'abord 2 ce plan devra
continuer à accélérer la mise à l'abri
et je peux vous assurer que c'est notre
priorité comment nous allons faire et
bien en continuant à construire des
pensions de famille construire des
résidences sociales en améliorant
l'accompagnement social des familles
parce que il faut accompagner les
familles avant pendant et après le
relogement et ça fait partie des
éléments forts du plan logement d'abord
bien évidemment et pour ceux qui me
connaissent un petit peu la
préoccupation qui sont exprimées par les
maires sont la préoccupation de tous les
maires de tous les élus qui sont
présents dans cette salle jamais nous
n'acceptons qu'une famille avec un
enfant soit à la rue jamais nous
n'acceptons en tout cas je l'espère que
ces enfants ne soient pas scolarisés et
ça fera aussi partie de nos priorités et
nous continuerons à les mener ensemble
et j'en parlerai dès demain avec
l'ensemble des sémers merci
votre réponse monsieur le ministre et je
ne mets pas en cause votre volonté
personnelle et votre expérience d'élue
locale sur cette question là ce que je
mets en cause c'est une vision globale
une politique globale du logement qui
n'existe pas tant que le logement sera
une variable d'ajustement budgétaire la
tribune des 20 maires appelle à déployer
en urgence un plan stratégique national
et transversal répondant à un diagnostic
clair et transparent que le gouvernement
a tout intérêt à produire rapidement ça
éviterait de contester les seuls
chiffres qui existent
il n'existe pour l'heure aucune
stratégie globale et je crois que la
vérité n'appartient à personne la
question c'est de savoir si nous voulons
travailler tous ensemble et ce n'est pas
un atelier du Conseil national de la
refondation tout seul qui va trouver la
solution vous avez déclaré les
associations sont mal inspirées quand
elles tombent dans l'outrans j'ai la
modestie et l'humilité de vous dire
qu'un gouvernement est mal inspiré quand
il tombe dans la suffisance ce n'est
certainement pas le meilleur moyen de
co-construire nous nous sommes prêts
ainsi que les vins mers qui vous ont
interpellé de co-construire et très vite
nous proposerons notre groupe une
proposition de loi nous verrons quelle
est la vraie volonté de co-construire
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue trois de
Bourras pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et de la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
en France de moins en moins d'adultes
aspirent à se retrouver devant une
classe devant des enfants pour les
instruire ou devrais-je dire tenter de
les instruire
professeur le plus beau métier du monde
après celui de parents disaient Charles
Péguy
comme cette affirmation semble d'un
autre temps oui notre pays vit une crise
évocation sans précédent dans certaines
matières comme les mathématiques il y a
moins de candidats que de postes à
pourvoir à peine plus de 6% des
enseignants français se sentent
considérés par la société l'un des pires
scores de l'OCDE oui le climat scolaire
s'est dégradé dans l'école de la
République dans un contexte de
recrutement difficile ce sont plus de
1600 enseignants qui ont démissionné en
2021 au point que le taux de professeur
démissionnaires étant hausse constante
depuis 10 ans oui le respect des règles
et de l'autorité font défaut dans nos
établissements scolaires la France est
le pays d'Europe où il y a le plus de
problèmes de discipline en classe seul
le Brésil et l'Argentine font moins bien
que l'océan dans l'OCDE monsieur le
ministre c'est cette réalité implacable
que des peintres de la Cour des comptes
sur le recrutement et la formation des
enseignants parus la semaine dernière
qui m'amène à vous poser la question
suivante que comptez-vous faire pour
réhabiliter enfin la vocation
d'enseignants et garantir à nos élèves
la transmission d'un savoir sans lequel
il n'y a plus de problèmes républicaines
[Applaudissements]
de la jeunesse merci monsieur le
Président Madame et messieurs les
sénateurs
bourra comme vous le savez le budget du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
augmente pour 2023 de
6,5% c'est une augmentation inédite et
tout à fait considérable cette
augmentation va permettre une meilleure
rémunération pour les enseignants et
cela bien entendu s'inscrit dans
l'amélioration de l'attractivité du
métier les problèmes d'attractivité je
le note au passage se pose dans la
plupart des pays européens presque tous
sauf deux et dans une majorité des pays
du monde mais nous devons nous attaquer
à cette question nous le faisons d'une
part par des augmentations de
rémunération pour tous les enseignants
et nous sommes en négociation avec les
organisations syndicales pour cela c'est
ce que nous appelons une augmentation
socle suivant en cela l'engagement du
président de la République une
augmentation
en moyenne de 10% pour les enseignants
et parallèlement à cela une augmentation
supplémentaire pour les enseignants qui
accepteront de nouvelles missions parmi
ces nouvelles missions j'en cite une qui
est tout à fait importante c'est celle
qui concerne les remplacements de courte
durée dans le secondaire nous perdons
chaque année 15 millions d'heures dans
l'enseignement secondaire en raison de
remplacement de courte durée moins de 15
jours qui ne sont pas assurés grâce à
ces nouvelles missions nous pourrons
assurer les remplacements de courte
durée de même que d'autres missions
importantes par exemple les heures de
soutien et d'approfondissement en
français et en mathématiques en classe
de 6e cela cet ensemble est également
négocié avec les organisations
syndicales je terminerai en disant que
la question du salaire n'est pas seule
lorsque l'on réfléchit sur
l'attractivité du métier il faut
réfléchir aussi sur les carrières les
jeunes ne s'engagent plus dans le métier
aujourd'hui comme les aînés jadis comme
ma génération on veut être professeur
pendant 10 ans et puis pouvoir faire
autre chose il faut imaginer des portes
d'entrée et les portes de sortie et donc
c'est tout cela
auquel nous réfléchissons pour faire de
telle sorte que le métier d'enseignant
retrouve toute sa centralité dans la
société française et toute son
attractivité
le mal-être dont souffre notre système
éducatif est connu de longue date le
plus beau métier du monde c'est vu
transformer en quelques années en une
mission impossible et votre mission
monsieur le ministre puisque vous l'avez
accepté c'est de faire que notre école
de nouveau soit le temple de la
connaissance et du respect
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue Bruno
rejoint pour le groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adressait
directement à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé absent aujourd'hui
Madame la Ministre délégué voilà 7 mois
que vous êtes en fonction et je souhaite
entendre de votre bouche les décisions
concrètes que vous avez prises avec
votre Ministre de tutelle pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux de tous les
groupes politiques de tous les
territoires par des rapports successifs
des débats des questions des
propositions de loi des amendements par
tous les véhicules législatifs possibles
le Sénat attend propose et exige des
décisions efficaces et concrètes pour
l'égalité d'accès aux soins de tous les
Français y compris de la ruralité
profonde
argument de votre ministère c'est
l'ensemble du pays qui fait face à une
pénurie de médecins certes mais avoir
cette conception uniforme c'est la
meilleure façon de ne pas agir car dans
la réalité certains territoires
souffrent beaucoup plus que d'autres et
le manque de praticien y est bien plus
important madame la ministre je vous le
dis
patient abandonné et mère à hier de
France ne peuvent plus supporter cette
situation inacceptable et indéfendable
ils attendent des décisions courageuses
et audacieuses qui dépendent de vous et
pas des comités machins choses qui
consomment du temps et ne ramène pas
véritablement la présence médicale dans
les territoires madame la ministre que
fait le gouvernement face à ce problème
majeur
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et
profession de santé madame fièrement le
Godot vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur nous partageons tous cette
conviction la santé et notre bien commun
le temps du diagnostic est dernière nous
nous sommes pleinement dans l'action
c'est le sens du cap fixé par le
président de la République le 6 janvier
dernier ce cap c'est celui de la
refondation de l'ensemble de notre
système de santé qu'il s'agisse de
l'hôpital ou de la médecine de ville à
l'hôpital notre volonté c'est de
redonner plus de sens plus de souplesse
et plus d'autonomie aux soignants cela
passe notamment par une meilleure
reconnaissance de la pénibilité mais
aussi par une refonte de l'organisation
à l'échelle des services ou une
modification de la sortie du toutes les
deux arbres pour la médecine de ville
nous souhaitons nous inscrire dans une
trajectoire à la fois pragmatique
ambitieuse et solidaire pragmatique
parce que nous manquons de personnels
soignants il nous faut donc assurer nous
assurer d'une chose simple nous
soignants doivent consacrer la majeure
partie de leur temps à soigner notre
objectif c'est de libérer des soignants
de une tâche administrative pour cela
vous le savez nous allons créer dix
mille postes d'assistants médicaux d'ici
la fin de l'année 2024 cela aussi passe
par des mesures de simplification de
tâches administratives ou de certains
cela suppression de certains certificats
médicaux inutiles nous ferons dans ce
sens des annonces dans les prochains
jours cela aussi passe par la
responsabilité de citoyens 28 millions
de rendez-vous ne sont pas honorés
chaque année ambitieuse parce que nous
souhaitons par ailleurs utiliser au
mieux les compétences de chacun il nous
faut utiliser toutes les ressources de
notre système notre volonté c'est une
meilleure travail en équipe et du
meilleur répartition des tâches entre
professionnels de santé autour du
médecin traitant ce médecin traitant
doit rester je le souligne à le
réaffirme la pierre angulaire de notre
système de santé ce que nous souhaitons
c'est créer autour de lui des équipes de
soins avec de la délégation d'acte entre
le médecin et les autres professionnels
être pragmatique et solidaire c'est
enfin mieux s'organiser à l'échelle des
territoires et des bassins de santé
c'est le sens du pacte territorial que
nous allons construire avec les élus
c'est aussi le sens de l'engagement
territorial du monde libéral dans une
logique de gagnant-gagnant nous avions
cela sur les CNR en santé vous voyez
monsieur sénateur nous sommes pleinement
engagés dans la refondation de notre
système de santé
monsieur rejoint
madame la madame la ministre
le constat on le connaît les solutions
tous les groupes avaient peut-être des
différences vous les ont apporté
maintenant il est temps de faire des
choix et de décider et c'est vous qui
devez décider ce qui apportera la
solution à la présence médicale dans
tous les territoires en France merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le 15 février je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour le débat
d'actualité sur le thème quelle réponse
européenne récente mesure
protectionniste américaine la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement on
va maintenant passer aux interviews à la
suite de cette séance et je suis avec le
ministre de l'Agriculture marcénot
bonjour bonjour alors aujourd'hui elle
les agriculteurs sont montés à la
capitale pour manifester contre le
retour de l'interdiction des
néonicotinoïdes sur les cultures de
betterave car il craignent bien des
pertes futures de récolte quelles
solutions le gouvernement leur propose
alors je les ai rencontrés ce matin
alors à la fois sur la question
particulière des betteraves et de la
conséquences de la décision de la Cour
de justice européenne c'est globalement
sur le sujet de la souveraineté et
comment on sort d'une logique qui part
des interdictions vient affaisser au
fond la souveraineté sur la betterave je
reverrai demain la filière ce que je
depuis le début je m'attache à essayer
de trouver des solutions et pas
simplement d'écrire les problèmes et
donc essayer de couvrir lit objectif et
de couvrir le risque sur la jaunisse
puisque et l'enrobage des graines on est
au nicotinoïd visé à empêcher que la
jaunisse apparaisse via les tronçons il
y a les pucerons et donc l'objectif
c'est de couvrir le risque sur l'année
2023 le risque qui est celui de perte de
récolte et donc de le couvrir à son
maximum pour faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs les betteraviers puissent
s'engager avec sérénité dans la
plantation de betterave c'est bien ça
l'objectif sur 2023 et puis deux c'est
de se donner des perspectives sur 2024
et 2025 à la fois la recherche de
solutions alternatives soit via des
produits phytosanitaires qui sont
autorisés soit via des tel type
alternatives sur lesquelles nous
travaillons il faut qu'on arrive à
avancer sur ces deux pieds alors il en
existe des alternatives ces solutions
mais est-ce qu'elles sont aussi
efficaces que les produits qui étaient
utilisés ça prouve bien qu'on avait
besoin d'une troisième année dérogation
sinon les alternatives soient déployées
sur le terrain et donc les alternatives
on a besoin de les crédibiliser parce
qu'elles ont besoin d'être explorées
dans certains cas on sait par exemple
qu'il y a des alternatives en termes de
semences qui soient qui ont fait de
produire des semences qui sont des
betteraves résistantes à la jaunisse bon
le temps de recherche le 2 ou 3 ans est
un temps court et donc on sait qu'il
faut un peu plus de temps que ceux qui
parfois sur les plateaux d'isiaca faucon
pour conclure on en est où de
l'interdiction en France du glyphosate
il y avait cette promesse d'Emmanuel
Macron de l'interdire en 2021 finalement
non tenu on en est où ce qui a été tenu
par le Président de la République c'est
la volonté de réduire la part du
glyphosate ce qui a été tenu aussi par
la de la part du président public c'est
la beauté de dire on évite les
surtranspositions et donc le débat il
est désormais un débat européen si c'est
autorisé en Allemagne il y a pas de
raison que ça soit pas autorisé en
France si c'est interdit en Allemagne et
dans le reste de l'espace européen je
dis les Allemands parce que c'est nos
voisins les plus importants en termes
agricole parmi les plus importants il
faut qu'il soit également autorisé en
France et donc il y a un travail qui
fait d'expertise au niveau européen il y
aura une réponse de l'agence de sécurité
sanitaire l'équivalent l'agence de
sécurité sanitaire au niveau européen à
la fin de l'année donc la solution sera
européenne merci beaucoup Marc créneau
d'être venu au micro de Public Sénat
merci merci beaucoup Alexandre et tout
de suite on rejoint Quentin dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat pour revenir sur
les temps forts de cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement oui parmi les
temps forts
de la réforme des retraites entre et
bien les sénateurs socialistes et le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Véran le point de départ c'est le PS qui
parle d'une réforme injuste et propose
de taxer les super profits à l'image de
ceux de total c'est Olivier Véran pour
le gouvernement qui lui a répondu s'en
est suivi cette passe d'armes Olivier
Véran ayant été lui-même et lui
socialiste dans les années 2010 et
écouter la suite
matière de pénibilité ce projet de loi
est porteur d'inventer social comme il y
en avait pas eu lors des précédents
projets de loi y compris celui que j'ai
été amené à voter lorsque j'étais député
socialiste et qu'à l'époque la gauche de
gouvernement ne renie pas les
fondamentaux qui étaient les siens à
savoir être capable de prendre des
décisions même difficiles quand il
fallait conforter notre modèle social à
savoir être capable de prendre des
décisions favorables à l'emploi dans
notre pays cette gauche que j'ai connu
et que j'ai quitté et je n'en ai pas de
regret aujourd'hui c'était une gauche
qui était capable de s'enthousiasmer
lorsque des entreprises créent de la
richesse et de l'emploi dans le pays
voilà Olivier Véran et qui n'est pas
voilà mécontent d'avoir quitté le PS et
le PS qui répondait en faisant signe
comme cela et bien nous non plus on voit
que c'est tendu depuis plusieurs
semaines entre par exemple Patrick
canaire et la chef du gouvernement
également entre Olivier dussobe et
Monique Lubin ces dernières semaines les
socialistes reprochent à ces ministres
venus de leur rang d'avoir eu des
revirements politiques autre moment fort
avec cet échange entre le président des
écologistes au Sénat Guillaume Gontard
et Elisabeth borne lui il a parlé de la
déclaration de politique générale de la
première ministre c'était en juillet
dernier à l'époque elle parlait bien de
rassembler autour de ces projets des
projets du gouvernement et bien cela a
beaucoup changé selon lui écouter la
réponse d'Elizabeth borne
et je le répète
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales les patronales avec les
groupes parlementaires il évoluera et
s'enrichira grâce au débat parlementaire
alors je sais que la dirigeante de votre
partie a appelé à faire du Parlement une
ZAD mais j'ai confiance dans la
responsabilité de chacun pour offrir aux
Français un débat de bonne tenue un
débat des idées et un débat respectueux
voilà la gauche qui est donc très
remontée contre cette réforme des
retraites Tam et ça annonce des séances
houleuses lorsque le texte arrivera au
Sénat ce sera donc au début du mois de
marstam merci merci beaucoup Quentin et
la réponse d'Elisabeth borne et bien
s'adresser à Guillaume Gontard le
président du groupe écologiste qui est
au micro d'Alexandre salle des
conférences
de la première ministre à votre question
qui dit et bien très bien les
propositions de la gauche d'augmenter
certaines cotisations d'augmenter les
impôts sur le capital mais ça peut créer
du chômage et puis ça peut entraîner une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat
pénibilité à la fois sur le financement
donc oui on les utilisera tout ce qui
existe dans le débat parlementaire pour
faire entendre notre voix évidemment
merci beaucoup Guillaume Gontard d'être
venu au micro de Public Sénat dans
quelques instants on sera avec votre
collègue président du groupe LR au
cinéma Bruno Retailleau merci beaucoup
Guillaume Gontard
c'est à VOUS Alexandre et publicain il y
a quelques divisions chez les LR et
notamment une sorte de fronde emmenée
par le député LR Aurélien Pradier qui
dit pour l'instant moi je ne vote pas
cette réforme de retraite en l'état car
je la trouve injuste et d'ailleurs il
interpelle il vous interpelle en disant
attention de votez pas une réforme
injuste qu'est-ce que vous voulez
répondez Bruno Retailleau je pense qu'il
se trompe il se trompe peut-être aussi
de famille politique nous on n'est pas
la gauche on est la droite notre ADN ça
a toujours été le courage la vérité et
la vérité c'est dire aux Français pas
peut-être ce qu'ils veulent absolument
entendre mais que si on ne fait rien
parce que on a de plus en plus de
retraités de moins en moins de jeunes de
cotisants parce que sur 10 ans on va
accumuler plus de 150 milliards d'euros
et bien on va mettre en l'air notre
modèle social voilà je pense que cette
réforme elle est perfectible mais très
franchement je ne comprends pas qu'il y
a encore deux mois il réclamait 45 à
nuités et que maintenant il est passé à
43 où est la cohérence où est la logique
je pense que au bout du compte en 2030
quand la réforme va s'appliquer on sera
le pays d'Europe de toute l'Europe qui
partira le plus tôt en retraite le pays
d'Europe où on aura les carrières
longues les plus généreuses la
pénibilité aussi le mieux prise en
compte ça oui et moi je me suis battu
pour les petites retraites je me battrai
aussi pour les maires de famille est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment coréen
Pradier en train de jouer une carte
personnelle finalement dans ce débat de
faire entendre sa petite musique bien
sûr bien sûr je pense que on peut
évidemment avoir des différences mais je
crois que cette surenchère cache cette
idée à la fois qu'il faut détruire en
tout cas troué de toute part la réforme
qui ne sera plus une réforme parce que
si elle ne produit pas les marges de
manoeuvre escomptés on sera en 2030 non
pas l'équilibre ou voir un excédent on
sera à nouveau en déficit et il faudra
prendre des mesures encore plus fortes
vous craignez cette douzaine de députés
les républicains qui pour l'instant sont
opposés à la réforme non non je pense et
je fais le pari d'ailleurs ça concerne
Aurélien Pradier que après cette
scénographie il va ce texte
un énorme problème pour notre famille
politique il devrait être exclu de cette
famille politique non mais je pense que
vis-à-vis de l'équipe dirigeante
s'imposera vraiment un vrai souci merci
beaucoup Bruno Retailleau d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci merci à
beaucoup Alexandre
écourtez aujourd'hui car tout de suite
on va prendre la direction de
l'Assemblée nationale nous allons
rejoindre l'Assemblée ou se déroule tout
le débat dans l'hémicycle sur la réforme
des retraites très bonne soirée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans 100% Senna il y a une semaine la
chambre haute a reçu le président de la
Rada le Parlement ukrainien et il a eu
des mots qui ont touché les sénateurs
cette phrase notamment on nous tue par
le froid et l'obscurité une semaine plus
tard le Sénat examine une proposition de
résolution elle est soutenue par de
nombreux présidents de groupe et elle
est portée par l'indépendant Claude
malurel vise a montré le soutien du
Sénat à l'Ukraine et à appeler au
renforcement de l'aide fournie je vous
laisse suivre les échanges je voudrais
tout le voir remercier les présidents de
groupe et les très nombreux sénateurs
qui ont décidé de consigner cette
proposition de résolution remercier
également le président du Sénat qui lui
confère une solennité particulière en
demandant lui-même son inscription à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat
un an après l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous
avons appris plusieurs leçons
fondamentales la première est l'ampleur
des mensonges que le Kremlin a orchestré
sans relâche depuis des années pour
justifier ses agressions successives
l'Occident est responsable de tout le
temps menace la Russie soutient des
nazis et des criminels de guerre
multiplient les provocations l'Europe et
le valet de l'impérialisme américain ces
discours délirants relayés avec
constance par le parti prorus en Europe
ont trompé beaucoup de monde ils ont
volé en éclat le jour où de juin dernier
à Saint-Pétersbourg ou Poutine lui-même
a fini par avouer ce qu'il pense depuis
toujours l'Ukraine et russe et comme au
temps de Pierre Legrand la Russie va
reprendre par la guerre ces territoires
perdus balayer la propagande balayer
tous les mensonges balayer la fable de
l'Occident menaçant empire colonial sous
les tsar la Russie fait le dernier
empire colonial sous le communisme après
la fin des empires anglais et français
elle veut le redevenir et l'on comprend
aujourd'hui le sens de la phrase
prononcée par Poutine en la chute de
l'URSS fut la plus grande catastrophe
politique du 20e siècle parce que la
chute de l'URSS c'était la fin de
l'Empire russe la deuxième leçon de
cette guerre et que l'ampleur de ses
mensonges n'a eu d'égal que l'ampleur de
nos illusions et de nos lâchetés ce
n'est pas l'agressivité de l'Occident
qui a conduit Poutine à envahir
l'Ukraine c'est sa passivité en 2008 les
leaders européens ont refusé à l'Ukraine
et à la Géorgie l'adhésion à l'OTAN pour
ne pas irriter Poutine quelques mois
plus tard il envahissait la Géorgie
quand il a envahi la Crimée nous avons
un nouveau répondu avec des sanctions
bien modestes il est clair que les
craintes infondées de provoquer Poutine
ont le convainquant de notre faiblesse
ont ouvert la voie à l'invasion totale
de 2022
cette erreur majeure d'analyse fut
d'abord celle de l'Allemagne et de la
France depuis 30 ans la politique
allemande est fondée sur la dépendance
énergétique à la Russie la dépendance
commerciale à la Chine et le désarmement
face aux deux celle de la France fut le
courtiser la Russie pour trianguler sa
relation avec les États-Unis en espérant
acquérir une position indépendante sans
en avoir les moyens politiques et
militaires que signifie puissance
d'équilibre quand il y a d'un côté une
démocratie qui est neutraliée depuis
plus de deux siècles qui nous a sauvés
lors de deux guerres mondiales et nous a
évité de devenir la province occidentale
du rail allemand ou de l'Union
soviétique et de l'autre une
cryptocratie mafieuse qui succède un
régime totalitaire ayant a servi
l'Europe pendant des décennies les
avertissements répétés les Européens de
l'Est qui savent eux ce que c'est que
l'impérialisme russe ont été rejetés
avec mépris comme des agitations de
vatte en guerre hystérique l'invasion de
l'Ukraine nous montre l'échec de ces
deux politiques et surtout l'urgence à
ne pas les poursuivre
l'apaisement et le compromis avec un
dictateur n'ont jamais marché le
dictateur avance devant la faiblesse et
recule devant la force c'est aussi
simple que ça depuis toujours si le rode
est une paix durable sur le continent
elle doit apprendre le langage de la
puissance le seul que les dictateurs
comprennent la troisième leçon est le
degré de nuisance de bassesse et de
complicité du parti prorus en Europe et
particulièrement en France cette
cinquième colonne des extrémistes qui
cherchent sans relâche à nous désarmer
face à un loup qu'il présente comme un
mouton qui depuis des années nous répète
que Poutine est le plus grand dirigeant
du monde qui reprennent notamment sur
les réseaux antisociaux avec les
milliers de fauconstes de trolls et de
bottes pilotés depuis Moscou sur les
télért et d'autres la propagande de
Poutine l'Ukraine n'existe pas elle est
russe ses dirigeants sont des nazis
Pouchkine le grand poétrus disait qu'on
nous donne une auge nous trouverons les
cochons
ils sont la boussole qui indique sans
jamais se tromper la direction du
déshonneur par le chemin le plus sordide
depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine Le Pen la
baronnette des guichets de Moscou et
Mélenchon le génufleteur des plus
infâmes dictatures condamnent du bout
des lèvres car ne pas le faire serait un
suicide mais il ne change pas d'avis
tout est de la faute de l'Occident
surtout pas d'armes surtout pas de
sanctions leur députés européens ont
refusé de voter même l'aide humanitaire
à l'Ukraine leur parlementaire français
ont refusé de voter l'entraide la Suède
et de la Finlande dans l'OTAN lors du
discours du président de la Rada
ukrainienne à l'Assemblée mardi dernier
ils ont déserté l'hémicycle pendant que
tous leurs collègues étaient debout pour
l'applaudir n'écoutez pas ce que disent
les dirigeants des parties de la France
russe regardez leur vote regardez leurs
gestes et vous comprendrez qu'ils n'ont
rien lâché qui sont toujours en
embuscade comme des crapauds blottis
sous une grosse pierre en attendant que
passe l'orage
que faire aujourd'hui
d'abord tirer les leçons de nos erreurs
passées car nous ne les endons pas
toutes tirés nous nous félicitons à
juste titre que l'Europe ne soit pas
divisée comme l'espérance Poutine mais
unis que notre alliance avec les
États-Unis et les autres démocraties se
soient renforcés que le soutien à
l'Ukraine reste constant que les
opinions publiques horrifiées par les
crimes de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité chaque jour sur leurs écrans
tiennent bon mais attention les
différences d'appréciations entre
européen de l'Ouest et européen de l'Est
et du Nord n'ont pas disparu et chaque
étape du conflit voit réapparaître
l'écart entre ceux qui se qualifient de
réalisme entre guillemets et ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin et plus vite les
réalistes se craignent l'escalade ils
pensent qu'il y a des lignes rouges à ne
pas franchir chaque épisode de cette
guerre prouve qu'ils ont tort en
refusant l'escalade ils en laissent le
monopole à Poutine et font perdre à
chaque fois les semaines nécessaires à
la contre-offensive c'est semaine c'est
moi parfois ce sont des milliers du
crânien qui meurent les lignes rouges
nous savons désormais qu'elles ne sont
que le fruit de nos peurs chaque fois
que Poutine les traces et qu'elles sont
franchies ils ne se passent rien comment
pourrait-il frapper plus fort alors que
son armée minée par la corruption qui
ronge son matériel l'incompétence de ces
chefs et la défiance de ces soldats est
déjà au-delà de son maximum et paralysé
sur tous les fronts quant à la rengaine
du danger nucléaire Poutine laisse
désormais mettre vedev le pochard et la
brosse le croque-mort les brandirs sur
les plateaux des trachets télé de Moscou
il a compris depuis la mortifiante
réunion de Samarcande
uchi et maudit l'ont mis publiquement en
piqué qu'elle lui est interdite même
parmi ces peines par ses propres proches
alliés
cessons de nous faire peur avec ce
disque rayé depuis 50 ans le but n'est
pas de permettre à l'Ukraine de résister
mais de chasser l'occupant si nous
avions livré dès le début ce que nous
nous apprêtons à livrer aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine n'aurait pas seulement
reconquis carqué avec Carson mais
largement profité dans le longbase
profitant de la déroute russe ce sera
bien plus difficile maintenant quand
leur a laissé le temps de se retrancher
mais c'est néanmoins un bon signe que de
plus en plus de dirigeants européens
hier dans le camp des réalistes soient
en train de comprendre que la livraison
massive d'armes n'aurait pas eu pour
conséquence de prolonger la guerre mais
au contraire de l'écourter par la
débâcle des envahisseur
mieux vaut tard que jamais c'est
maintenant qu'il faut livrer les chars
les missiles les défenses solaires et
les avions si nous voulons comme le
Prométhée le président de la République
lors de ses vœux accompagner l'Ukraine
jusqu'à la victoire finale il est enfin
une dernière raison encore plus
essentielle de ne pas répéter les
erreurs du passé les démocraties au
terme d'une lutte implacable ont vaincu
au 20e siècle les deux totalitarismes
aux dizaines de millions de morts
certains les croyaient disparus à jamais
sous nos yeux l'international des tyrans
se reforment le boucher de Moscou le
génocidaire des Ouigours en Chine le
Docteur Folamour de Corée du Nord le
massacreur de femmes de Téhéran et
quelques autres se sont regroupés leur
seul but se venger abattre l'Occident
mettre à bas la liberté la deuxième
guerre froide a commencé et depuis
plusieurs années beaucoup de dirigeants
occidentaux proclament que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre la Russie
j'espère bien que ce discours n'est que
tactique et qu'il n'en croit pas un mot
parce que les dictateur eux l'annoncent
clairement ils sont en guerre contre
nous
ils veulent achever les démocraties
qu'il croit agonisantes il n'y aurait
rien de pire que de croire que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre des gens qui
sont en guerre contre nous et qui le
disent quand on reste du monde il attend
l'issue du conflit pour voler au secours
de la victoire ce qui en espéraient une
certaine sympathie se trompent
lourdement les dirigeants bien peu
démocratiques de la plupart de ces pays
se moquent de savoir si Poutine a violé
les lois internationales ils ont même
pour mantra la justification de leurs
méfaits actuels par la condamnation de
notre domination passée l'Europe doit
comprendre l'urgence de redevenir une
puissance militaire d'avoir une
stratégie commune et de consolider notre
alliance avec les autres démocraties du
monde à commencer par les États-Unis si
nous n'y arrivons pas
si nous laissons les cinquième colonnes
des fachos des trottes des populistes et
des idiots utiles nous conduire à
l'aveuglement et aux renoncement alors
ce n'est pas seulement l'Ukraine demain
qui sera vaincu mais la liberté il est
temps de réarmer les démocraties face au
tyrannie du 21e siècle le peuple
héroïque du crâne nous en montre le
chemin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Grand pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues sidéré par
la brutalité des événements du crâne
depuis le 24 février dernier nous nous
devons de garder la mémoire du temps
long pour en saisir le sens et la portée
sachant ne pas oublier la longue période
de dictature et d'oppression du régime
communiste dans l'URSS alors et
l'enfermement de ce régime dans une
confrontation toujours plus acharnée
sachant ne pas oublier ce qu'on
signifier la chute du mur de Berlin et
la partition de son empire source de
nostalgie de ressentiment parmi les
dirigeants et ses forces armées Vladimir
Poutine a jamais fait mystère de ses
sentiments sur cette page d'histoire qui
l'a rappelé en 2005 la plus grande
catastrophe géopolitique du 20e siècle
les frontières de la Russie s'inscrire
dans l'histoire comme le dirigeant qui
lèvera les affront de l'histoire
contemporaine à son pays c'est son
obsession en 2008 Vladimir Poutine a
jeté son dévolu sur l'océi en Géorgie et
6 ans plus tard sur le dombases et la
Crimée le 24 février dernier
l'emballement de l'histoire nous rappela
que la Russie n'avait pas renoncé à
conquérir l'Ukraine dans l'esprit les
nationalistes russes une victoire
militaire en quelques semaines contre
l'Ukraine ce serait traduite par un
triangle de la ligne routine
dans cet esprit Poutine tente
aujourd'hui de réhabiliter Staline pour
remotiver un nationalisme russe
confronté au doute que lui inspire les
revers de l'armée russe la réalité est
bien là la Russie est loin d'avoir pu
conquérir l'Ukraine et remplacer le
gouvernement de Kiev la lumière Poutine
a sous-estimer la réaction occidentale
et en particulier la capacité de l'Union
européenne d'organiser son unité pour
porter secours à une nation voisine
envahie
les États-Unis par leur envoi massive
d'équipement militaire leur aide
financière affiche leur soutien moral et
politique à l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine
et ses généraux en sous-estimé la force
et du patriotisme du peuple ukrainien
ses capacités militaires tactiques
mécaniques et bien sûr le courage la
force politique du président zeninski
qui a su mobiliser son peuple et obtenir
le soutien d'une d'un grand nombre de
démocratie mes chers collègues
l'indici de cette guerre s’écrivent sa
barbarie ses milliers et milliers de
morts la déportation de citoyens et même
d'enfants tout cela l'histoire ne
l'oubliera pas tôt ou tard les
dirigeants russes devront rendre compte
mais aujourd'hui chaque Français
voudrait voir cesser cette guerre aux
conséquences désormais ressenties dans
leur vie quotidienne monsieur le
ministre
beaucoup s'interrogent sur le rôle de la
France
ici au Sénat nous savons que la France
plus qu'on est qu'au que notre pays a
conscience que son soutien sans réserve
à l'Ukraine ne la dispense pas au
contraire l'oblige à maintenir une
action diplomatique ambitieuse et dans
un même temps à livrer de l'armement aux
Ukrainiens et en plus sécurisé sa
présence sur tous les continents la
France dans l'engagement pour la paix
n'est plus à démontrer seul État de
l'Union européenne à disposer d'un siège
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU se doit
de développer une diplomatie de temps
guerre c'est sa ligne politique de
toujours
la France voit de la paix c'est
anticiper les cataclysmes souvenons-nous
il y a 20 ans presque jour pour jour de
la position de Jacques Chirac et du
discours Dominique de Villepin à l'ONU
contre la guerre en Irak le message de
la supériorité du droit sur la force
reste plus que jamais d'actualité
aujourd'hui qui peut imaginer que le
Président de la République sa ministre
des Affaires étrangères et notre
diplomatie ne sont pas de la même
stratégie de lucidité pour aider à jeter
les bases d'une paix durable en Ukraine
sans renier ou affaiblir le soutien
occidental à cette nation martyr et
encore moins l'amener à renoncer à ses
frontières reconnues par l'ONU par les
Nations Unies cette salière menée par la
Russie s'étend aussi dans le même temps
auprès des pays émergents dont les
peuples vivants de la pauvreté sont une
proie facile pour Vladimir Poutine et sa
milice Wagner
les récents coups d'État militaires en
Afrique facilite le retournement contre
la France des populations abusées une
déstabilisation de l'Afrique conduira
mécaniquement à l'exode de ces
populations vers le continent européen
voilà une arme redoutable imaginée par
le Kremlin pour déstabiliser l'Europe
déstabiliser la France pour l'Afrique
pour déstabiliser l'Europe c'est aussi
cela la guerre que nous mène la lumière
Poutine enfin une autre conséquence de
la guerre à l'Ukraine et la stratégie
russe que la France doit gérer avec ses
partenaires dans sa diversité et sa
complexité c'est le risque du retour
d'un sentiment politique quand on
l'Occident qui ne manquera pas là aussi
de créer de multiples problèmes de tous
ordres aux quatre coins du monde des
alliances improbables il y a encore
quelques mois où j'ai presque fini une
réalité dès lors qu'elle servirait les
intérêts de la nation voilà quelques
raisons mes chers collègues qui forment
notre détermination à soutenir l'Ukraine
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Guillaume Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 5
minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a près
d'un an jour pour jour vladivir Poutine
plongez l'Europe et le monde dans le
chaos en agressant son voisin ukrainien
un an plus tard le bilan de cette
invasion devenu une guerre de tranchée
d'un autre âge et terrifiant alors que
les soldats se battent dans la neige et
le froid glacial de l'hiver continental
le conflit aurait déjà fait plusieurs
centaines de milliers de victimes dans
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de civils
ukrainiennes et ukrainiens
la Russie qualifiée par le Parlement
européen d'État promouvant le terrorisme
devra répondre de ses crimes qu'il me
soit permis à cette tribune de
renouveler au peuple ukrainien notre
hommage le plus vibrant et notre
admiration devant l'immense courage qui
est le sien vous admirons tant le
courage des militaires qui défendent la
ligne de front pièce à pied face aux
vagues des malheureux construirus
envoyés à la mort que le courage des
civils vivant à l'arrière sous la menace
des bombes et des drones qui prennent
des vies et détruisent les
infrastructures civiles pour plonger le
pays dans le noir le froid la soif et la
solitude de l'hiver
un an plus tard le bilan de cette guerre
est déjà planétaire crise énergétique
inflation pénurie alimentaire l'économie
mondiale qui était à peine sortie de la
pandémie de covid-19 et de nouveau
plongée la tête sous l'eau les
perspectives à court terme sont
alarmantes le Programme Alimentaire
Mondial des Nations Unies considère que
nous sommes face à leur pire crise
alimentaire depuis la fin de la
troisième guerre mondiale plus que
jamais nos efforts de coopération
doivent être décuplés pour éviter de
mettre sur les routes des millions
d'affamés
un an plus tard nous remercions le
groupe Les Indépendants liberté et
territoire et son président Claude
malurey même avec certaines de ces
outrances déplacées de proposer à notre
examen cette proposition de résolution
pour exprimer le soutien du Sénat à
l'Ukraine cette guerre a trop durée nous
devons tout faire pour atteindre son
terme cela passe par un renforcement du
soutien à l'Ukraine pour lui permettre
de repousser l'envahisseur russe et de
recouvrer ses frontières de 1991 on peut
légitimement s'en inquiéter et le
déplorer mais aucune autre alternative
née sur la table la France recevait la
semaine dernière monsieur rousselens
Stephen Chuck président le Rada qui nous
a présenté la situation suivante soit
nous livrons à l'Ukraine davantage
d'armement de pointe pour lui permettre
de percer à nouveau le front et
d'avancer vers l'Est soit la guerre va
inévitablement s'enliser dans un
mercurier conflit de tranchées ou
périront tant de soldats que la Russie a
en nombre supérieur
si cette guerre s'étire sur plusieurs
années les conséquences seront
désastreuses pour l'Ukraine et pour le
monde entier aussi nous sommes
favorables à ce que la France et ses
alliés renforce leurs efforts en matière
de soutien militaire financiers et de
ravitaillement à ce titre nous demandons
solennellement au président de la
République de livrer quelques chars à
l'Ukraine au-delà de son efficacité
militaire que nous savons limitée cette
décision est indispensable politiquement
elle doit garantir à nos alliés que la
France est à leur côté dans toutes les
décisions importantes que cette guerre
exige de nous dès à présent se posera la
question de la fourniture d'avion de
chasse demandée par le président zenzky
la plus épineuse à ce jour ayant
constaté le grand sang-froid dans font
preuve le pouvoir politique et
l'état-major ukrainien nous croyons
possibles de fournir collectivement des
chasseurs à l'Ukraine sans risquer de
les voir utiliser à d'autres fins que la
défense de son territoire aussi nous
invitons les part
entamé pardon des discussions en ce sens
nous saluons le nouveau paquet de
sanctions annoncé par la présidente de
la Commission européenne et nous
appelons comme le demande le président
ukrainien ayant inclure les dirigeants
de rosatum à défaut de pouvoir nous
passer de l'uranium enrichi en Russie
pour notre fourniture électrique nous
saluons la décision historique de la
Norvège d'allouer une aide plus réelle
de près de 7 milliards d'euros à
l'Ukraine tant pour le soutien immédiat
au pays que pour sa reconstruction
future et nous invitons la France et
l'Union européenne à agir dans le même
sens cela doit aussi inclure une aide de
matériel au besoin logistiques immédiat
notamment l'envoi de groupe électrogène
enfin pour finir sur une perspective
optimiste nous saluons les progrès
réalisés par l'Ukraine dans son chemin
vers l'adhésion à l'Union chemin que
nous souhaitons le plus court possible
l’une des causes de ce conflit c'est
justement la volonté de l'Ukraine de
rejoindre l'Europe comme nous l'avons
été depuis un an nous devons nous devons
d'être indéfectiblement à la hauteur de
cet idéal de liberté et de démocratie
que des flancs le peuple ukrainien voilà
mes chers collègues nous adopterons
naturellement cette résolution et
souhaitons que le vote de notre
assemblée soit une anime merci
le président la parole est à Monsieur
André gatolin pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes faisaient indépendant pour
6 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
préambule à mon propos je veux tout
d'abord remercier très chaleureusement
notre collègue Claude Malhuret qui a
porté cette initiative nous connaissons
tous ici sa vigilance de longue date à
l'endroit du régime de Vladimir Poutine
les propos ferment et constants qu'il
tient à ce sujet ici au Sénat depuis
2014 l'honneur et indirectement honore
notre assemblée au delà je tiens
également à saluer l'ampleur du soutien
qui s'est déjà exprimé en faveur de
cette proposition de résolution et en
particulier son caractère éminemment
trans partisan puisque pas moins de cinq
présidents de groupe sans son
signataires ce quasi consensus est
d'autant plus remarquable que les termes
employés par cette proposition sont
fermes précis et sans équivoque c'est il
est vrai le moins que nous puissions
faire face à cette agression horrible
perpétée à l'encontre de l'Ukraine cette
guerre hybride et haute intensité avec
son cortège inouï d'exaction et de
crimes de guerre dans la liste s'allonge
malheureusement chaque jour davantage ce
texte arrive aussi à un moment clé du
conflit pas seulement parce que nous
approchons du 24 février date
anniversaire du début de cette guerre
non nous sommes à un moment clé parce
que contrairement à ce qui avait prédit
certains commentateurs le fameux général
hiver n'a pas gelé ce conflit bien au
contraire les combats redoublent
d'intensité dans des zones qui
s'étendent ou du sud de zaporiggia au
nord de bakhout certes nous disposons
pas de chiffres officiels mais on évalue
à au moins 120 150 000 morts le nombre
de soldats russes qui ont été tués et à
plus de 100.000 le nombre du crinien
civils et militaires ayant connu le même
sort le moment est clé car après une
phase de reconquête entamée par
l'Ukraine à l'automne passée nous sommes
désormais dans une guerre de position où
les
ukrainiennes sont sur la défensive tant
les moyens humains déployés par la
Russie sont importants les moyens
militaires de l'Ukraine en dépit de
l'aide prodigués sont insuffisants pour
tenir sérieusement une ligne de front
qui à l'est s'étend sur plus de 1500 km
et à laquelle il faut bien sûr ajouter
les 900 km de frontières avec la
Biélorussie ou le régime de Monsieur
lucaschenko définitivement vastalisée
par le Kremlin fait figure de complices
de celui-ci condamné fermement
l'attitude de la Russie qui dans tous
les domaines rond avec le droit
international le droit humanitaire et le
droit de la guerre est indispensable
Alexandra m'avait chouk présidente du
centre des libertés civiques déclarait
il y a dix jours devant l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe que
son organisation je rappelle lauréate du
prix Nobel de la paix en 2022 avait
censé documenté plus de 31
000 crimes de guerre perpète par les
troupes russes et encore ne s'agit-il là
que des crimes possiblement responsables
car il en est certain dans les
territoires de l'est de l'Ukraine annexé
ou occupé par la Russie qui ne peuvent
être ni documentés ni précisément
quantifier c'est la raison sans doute
pour laquelle on déplie de leur extrême
gravité plusieurs de ses crimes sont si
elliptiquement évoqués dans cette
résolution je pense en particulier à la
situation de centaines de milliers
d'enfants qui ont été déplacés de force
vers le territoire russe
osons le mot c'est bien une déportation
de masse sans précédentes en Europe
depuis la Seconde guerre mondiale qui
est à l'oeuvre les médias propagandistes
russes regorgent le reportage louant
Jean s’était lent de soi-disant
solidarité humanitaire de famille
risques qui adopte spontanément ces
pauvres orphelins de guerre orphelins
qui en réalité disposent souvent encore
de parents en Ukraine en fait et le
Kremlin ne s'engage hier il procède à ce
qu'il appelle la dénazification des
territoires occupés en désucrinisant les
déportés en procédant à leur
rucification portée à travers leurs
changements de nom voire même d'origine
à l'état civil bien plus qu'une
épuration ethnique constitutive en soi
déjà d'un crime contre l'humanité ce
procédé honteux visant éradiquer
l'identité d'enfants et aller prendre en
otage s'apparente un acte constitutif
d'un véritable génocide aussi au-delà de
cette résolution en faveur de laquelle
mon groupe le groupe RDPI se prononcera
unan je voudrais conclure mon propos en
interpellant notre haute assemblée sur
une question qui jusqu'à présent
Lagerfel objet de son attention on le
sait Rome ne sait pas construite en un
jour le pouvoir autoritaire de Vladimir
Poutine non plus son attitude n'a pas
soudainement basculé dans la nuit du 23
au 24 février 2022 qui est entraîné son
pays dans cette guerre un diable depuis
15 ans au moins des signes
avant-coureurs jalonné de sang
préfigurait déjà les charniers que nous
commençons à déterrer aujourd'hui
pourquoi n'avons pas vu venir cette
guerre et la dérive démocratique est
bellicise de son principal artisan
avons-nous été aveuglé où nous sommes
nous laissés aveugler l'argument de
l'imprésivie imprévisibilité et de
l'iranalité supposée de Vladimir poutur
Poutine à Bondo pour expliquer les
erreurs d'analyse stratégiques nous
avons commises alors ou de multiples
travaux de retours d'expérience sur
cette guerre sont engagées je crois
qu'un peu d'introspection sur nos
faiblesses passées ici ne serait sans
doute pas
inutile je vous remercie de votre
attention
minute
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
voilà 349 jours la Fédération de Russie
a décidé sur ordre de son président
Poutine l'invasion d'un autre pays
souverain l'Ukraine en violation du
droit international cela fait 349 jours
qu'un peuple souffre cela fait 349 jours
qu'un peuple est bombardé cela fait 349
jours qu'un peuple se bat pour sa
liberté et au travers de liberté la
nôtre
au Sénat depuis presque un an nous avons
suivi l'évolution de la situation et
nous sommes réunis nous nous sommes
réunis de multiples reprises encore la
semaine dernière nous avons entendu les
mots forts du président de la radar
rosslan Stefan qui disait on nous tue
par le froid et l'obscurité et un autre
moment de la journée il nous avait dit
la Russie a volé un an de la vie de
l'Ukraine
ces mots ne peuvent pas rester sans écho
et je salue donc l'initiative du
président du groupe Les Indépendants
liberté et territoires qui a initié
cette proposition de résolution elle
nous permet en premier lieu de regarder
derrière nous et de tirer un premier
bilan de cette année de guerre en Europe
afin de tracer les perspectives qui
devront conduire vers une paix
victorieuse pour l'Ukraine et les
Ukrainiens
le 26 octobre dernier nous avons eu un
débat très riche très fort nous avons
condamné
dénoncer cette invasion et ses
conséquences notamment à l'égard des
populations civiles nous avons condamné
une invasion et des exactions contraires
au droit international nous n'oublierons
pas bout de chat irpin Mario Paul et
toutes les autres villes martyrs nous
sommes inquiétés les conséquences
collatérales pour l'Europe et pour le
monde particulièrement en matière
d'énergie et de sécurité alimentaire
nous nous sommes interrogés sur les
risques d'usure que fait peser cette
guerre une usure qui pourrait atteindre
la solidarité le soutien des pays et de
leurs concitoyens à la cause de
l'Ukraine
c'est quelques mois qui nous séparent de
ce dernier débat permettent de faire un
certain nombre de constats et de tirer
quelques leçons
le premier de ces constat est que le
soutien à l'Ukraine reste non seulement
indéfectible mais il se renforce dans
l'opinion malgré l'inflation malgré les
coûts de l'énergie nos concitoyens n'ont
pas fléchi et l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne c'est même renforcée les pays
européens les Alliés ont non seulement
continué à faire preuve de solidarité
mais il ne cesse de renforcer leur aide
qu'elle soit financières militaires ou
diplomatique et l'Union européenne a su
démontrer ses capacités de ressources
pour affronter les turbulences nous
devons pas relâcher l'effort et
continuer à relever collectivement
certains défis qui n'ont pas encore été
traités j'y reviendrai
le second constat et que le soutien en
termes de matériel notamment un produit
les effets l'armée ukrainienne a pu
mettre à son actif une reconquête d'une
partie de ces territoires l'armée russe
détenait 24,4% du territoire ukrainien
en mars 2022 aujourd'hui l'on contrôle
plus que 18%. ces modestes mais c'est
une avancée les premiers responsables en
sont bien sûr les Ukrainiens dont le
courage et la compagnie la combativité
continue aujourd'hui d'être à l'oeuvre
sur les différents fronts on pense
notamment à baroute où les combats sont
particulièrement violents et à d'autres
zones où la situation reste très fragile
enfin l'escalade tant crainte n'a pas eu
lieu en tout cas pas sous la forme que
certains prédisaient la seule escalade
que l'on observe et celle de la violence
utilisée par l'armée russe à l'encontre
du peuple ukrainien en effet nous avons
changé nous avons observé un changement
de nature de la stratégie russe qui
s'est mise à cibler délibérément
systématiquement les infrastructures
critiques
ukrainien et les populations civiles
dans une fuite en avant à caractère
mortifère contraire à toutes les lois
cette stratégie ne peut que renforcer
notre détermination à nous tenir aux
côtés des Ukrainiens alors oui les
infrastructures nous aiderons à les
reconstruire alors oui les populations
nous continuerons à les soutenir et je
réussis une pensée mes chers collègues
pour les Français qui sont encore en
Ukraine certains dans l'est du pays sous
les bombes notamment à cariffe ils ne
sont pas partis car leur vie et là-bas
leur attache familiale sont là-bas
certains n'ont pas les capacités
financières pour partir et les contacts
nécessaires en France pour le faire il
ne faut pas les oublier monsieur le
ministre et à leur côté pour répondre à
leurs éventuelles demandes
cette résolution nous amène à nous
interroger sur les prochaines étapes
nécessaires pour aboutir à sortir de ce
conflit
personne sur ces banques comme partout
ailleurs personne ne veut la guerre
nous recherchons le retour à une
situation passive mais nous devons être
clair sur un point quitte à nous répéter
et à nous répéter nous ne pouvons viser
autre chose que la victoire de l'Ukraine
sur son agresseur russe je l'ai déjà dit
ici je le répète aucun traité ne serait
être arraché par la force c'est d'égal à
égal sous la projection de l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale rassemblée
au sein de l'ONU que l'Ukraine et la
Fédération de Russie doivent définir les
modalités de leur coexistence même si
nous savons qu'elle sera difficile
notamment dans les premiers temps une
fois nous l'espérons la paix retrouver
car tout démontre que c'est dans un
rapport de force y compris militaire
avec Poutine que la voix de la
diplomatie pourrait être pour être
pardon retrouvé lui seul nous oblige à
réagir ainsi ne l'oublions pas pour
atteindre ce but
il convient de saluer le saut qualitatif
de l'aide militaire des chars seront
fournis
avec le temps nécessaire pour cette
livraison ils seront un renfort de poids
pour la l'armée ukrainienne des avions
pour l'être également la stratégie
ukrainienne reste et doit rester une
stratégie défensive que nous devons
soutenir par ses moyens elle l'a
toujours été parce que c'est l'Ukraine
qui est la nation agressée et ses
l'Ukraine qui doit pouvoir se défendre
un renfort d'autant plus nécessaire que
la Russie a des ressources que ce soit
en termes de matériel comme de soldats
on ne connaît pas encore les effets de
la massification de son armée sur une
éventuelle future offensive à la fin de
l'hiver ou au début du printemps
comment depuis le début de la guerre
l'aide européenne doit être combiné avec
des sanctions pour l'économie russe il
convient de saluer le nouveau paquet de
sanctions annoncé par Ursula vanderleyen
pour le 24 février prochain date
anniversaire entre guillemets si l'on
peut dire de l'invasion dans ce cadre la
résolution site notamment la Biélorussie
qui fait partie de l'équation n'oublions
pas non plus cet état vassal du régime
de Moscou et ayant une pensée pour les
opposants biélorusses emprisonnés ou
exilés
comme le texte l'évoque nous devons
combiner notre action avec une réflexion
plus poussée qui pourra aboutir à des
enquêtes sur les faits susceptibles de
constituer des crimes de guerre des
crimes contre l'humanité l'Europe
travaille sur différentes pistes en ce
sens la France monsieur le ministre
devra prendre toute sa part dans ce
cadre
la guerre nous oblige à l'humilité comme
la résolution nous y invite plusieurs
questions restent à trancher au niveau
français à l'échelle européenne et au
sein de l'OTAN et je voudrais les
partager avec vous mes chers collègues
comment établir le basculement
stratégique comment reprendre l'avantage
dans le cadre d'une stratégie défensive
comment reconstruire l'Ukraine sur ce
dernier point la France devra y
participer aux côtés de ses partenaires
à ce stade le classement zone rouge de
l'ensemble de l'Ukraine par le ministère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
empêche les entreprises françaises dit
participer il faudra y travailler
cette humilité nous devons également
l'appliquer à la France cette guerre
interroge nos certitudes et nous devons
dès aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
réfléchir ensemble sur les capacités
militaires qui nous permettent de
protéger notre pays sur la réaffirmation
de notre place dans le temps sur la
place de la France sur le continent
européen et au niveau international ou
encore sur nos capacités économiques et
industrielles cette réflexion doit
s'inscrire à l'islamation nationale mais
aussi dans le cadre européen ce sont des
chantiers importants mes chers collègues
pour conclure nous ne devons pas
craindre Vladimir Poutine
quand celui-ci souligne qu'à travers
l'Ukraine il fait la guerre à l'Occident
monsieur Poutine est un prédateur il
profitera de chacune de nos faiblesses
et ces provocations verbales lors de la
célébration de la victoire de Stalingrad
Julie dernier ont pour héros
l'exaltation d'un patriotisme agressif
alors soyons forts sachons résister oui
c'est un prédateur à l'extérieur de chez
frontières comme à l'intérieur de ses
frontières le peuple russe comporte
aussi son lot d'opposant à la guerre ce
qui ne veulent pas que leurs enfants se
fasse dévorer par le nationalisme ceux
qui ne veulent pas que la dictature
s’étende sur le monde sachant écouter
leur voix même s'il est encore faible et
réprimé Tolstoï faut conclure chers
collègues
Tolstoï a écrit que la vérité doit
s'imposer sans violence je regrette que
le dîner Poutine est fait mentir cette
maxime mais j'espère qu'elle s'imposera
demain et que la justice et les droits
du peuple crânien seront rétablis le
courage de l'Ukraine nous oblige
est au président Pierre Laurent pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
la résolution que nous discutons arriva
à un moment crucial pour l'avenir du
conflit et pour celui de la paix
mondiale hier le secrétaire général de
l'ONU s'est alarmé je le cite que le
monde se dirige les yeux grands ouverts
vers une guerre plus large encore
mettant en garde contre les risques
d'escalade allons-nous entendre chers
collègues cette mise en garde il y a un
an l'agression militaire déclenchée par
Vladimir Poutine a plongé dans l'aurore
le peu plus craignant et signer le
retour d'une guerre inhumaine au cœur de
l'Europe le bilan est d'ores et déjà
effroyable probablement plus de 300 000
victimes tuées ou blessées un pays
durablement meurtri des millions de
réfugiés de déplacés en termes Vladimir
Poutine croyait gagner la guerre en un
éclair la résistance de l'Ukraine et
départ la France et l'OTAN a changé la
donne face à cette résistance qu'il
n'attendait pas VLAN Poutine a choisi le
pire toujours plus de guerre de crimes
de destruction de une relation des
droits humains dont roulement forcé de
jeunes Russes sans compter le chantage
plusieurs fois brandi de la menace
nucléaire ce choix du pire a provoqué en
riposte un armement massif de l'Ukraine
un an plus tard malgré cet effrayant
bilan des moyens colossaux engagés de
part et d'autre et une ligne de front
globalement figée depuis des mois la
guerre ne s'apaise pas mais semble au
contraire à l'aube d'une nouvelle
escalade et cela en dépit du constat
dressé par le général Mac Millet chef
d'état-major des armées des États-Unis
le 9 novembre 2022
estimant je cite il doit y avoir une
reconnaissance mutuelle que la victoire
n'est probablement pas réalisable par
des moyens militaires et qu'il faut donc
se tourner vers d'autres moyens
j'entends aussitôt la critique admettre
admettre ce constat ce serait ainsi être
indifférent au drame ukrainien ou pire
se montrer complice de Vladimir Poutine
le président de la République lui-même
Emmanuel Macron a été confronté à cette
accusation larvée quand il a tenté de
maintenir ouverte la porte du
négociation sommet alors de rentrer dans
le rang des partisans de l'escalade
guerrière
non chers collègues affirmait notre
soutien à l'Ukraine contre l'agression
militaire de la Fédération de Russie
dénoncer les crimes de Vladimir Poutine
exiger le retrait des troupes russes et
le respect de la souveraineté de
l'Ukraine et des militairement et
humanitairement l'Ukraine à se défendre
et à protéger sa population c'est
indispensable comme nous le disons
depuis le premier jour de la guerre mais
cela de loi allait de père avec
l'impératif de prévenir une guerre
généralisée
et aller de pair avec une mobilisation
internationale de tous les instants pour
stopper le conflit pour explorer toutes
les voix capables de remettre les
belligérants à la table de négociation
en vue du retour à la paix et à la
sécurité mutuelle abandonner l'objectif
de la paix au sol profit de l'escalade
militaire
s'établiqués devant la perspective d'une
guerre longue et durable toujours plus
destructrice une guerre aux limites
inconnue chaque jour plus proche d'un
basculement conséquences un calculable
ce travail est urgentissime chers
collègues ne voyons nous pas s'accumuler
les vents mauvais d'une guerre toujours
plus large la Russie nous recule devant
rien pour envoyer la jeunesse russe à la
boucherie face à lui le surarmement des
pays de l'OTAN s'accélèrent dans des
proportions inédites les ventes d'armes
à l'international des États-Unis ont
dépassé les 200 milliards de dollars
inondales inondant l'Europe d'armes
toujours plus sophistiqués les
dirigeants polonais pas à proprement
parler des figures de la démocratie ont
augmenté le budget militaire de 9
milliards de d'euros en 2015 à 97
milliards en 2023 à grands coups
d'équipements américains
les surenchères nationalistes et les
réécritures de l'histoire se propage
partout et ont tous sens excitant les
haines des peuples au même moment nous
voyons nous pas excusez-moi nous voyons
nous rien de tout cela des périls ont
couru européens ayant traversé deux
guerres mondiales avons-nous perdu la
mémoire voilà pourquoi chers collègues
nous ne voterons pas la résolution qui
nous est proposée elle énonce des
rappels de principes que nous défendons
nous-mêmes face à l'agression criminelle
de la Russie mais elle ne propose face à
ce drame qu'un seul chemin de fête
l'escalade militaire clairement
revendiquée par l'auteur de cette
proposition de résolution Claude malurey
c'est le sens de l'alinéa 31
autrement dit après les chars lourds
porteurs d'obus à uranium ou appauvri
des avions de chasse demain des missiles
et à chaque grand nouveau des soldats
formateurs de l'OTAN directement engagés
la résolution donne en fait le feu vert
aux franchissement futur de toutes les
lignes rouges et surtout elle fait
l'impasse sur tout appel à une
initiative de négociation et de paix ce
n'est pas en oubli c'est un choix celui
de la guerre comme seul chemin possible
oubliant la leçon de tous les conflits
récents cette résolution est une
occasion manquée je conclus d'une phrase
celle de faire rimer solidarité avec
l'Ukraine et mobilisation pour une
solution de paix c'est cette double
exigence qui exprimera notre vote contre
merci la parole est à Madame Nadia solo
pour le groupe Union centriste pour 4
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes
chers collègues depuis un an les
auditions menées par le groupe d'amitié
France Ukraine que je préside ne parle
ni des changes culturels ni de
partenariat économique les auditions que
nous menons sont des récits d'horreur de
souffrance et de terreur des récits de
courage et de résilience à chaque
entretien nous promettons de porter des
messages je remercie donc Claude malurey
qui me donne aujourd'hui l'occasion de
le faire une tribune qui ne sera pas la
mienne mais celle de ceux qui souffrent
et nous appellent au secours ce sera
aussi la tribune d'un groupe d'amitié
qui n'a jamais relâché ses efforts
le 23 mars 2022 nous étions une
vingtaine devant l'ambassade de Russie à
Paris nous portions un message simple
exigeant le respect des termes de la
Convention de Genève signé par la
Fédération de Russie nous demandions
d'urgence des corridors humanitaires
pour les populations civiles nous
portions les signatures de 170 d'entre
vous sénateurs de France nous n'avons
pas été reçus traités avec le plus grand
des mépris le 7 février 2023 nous
exigeons de nouveau le respect des
règles essentielles du droit humanitaire
international le respect des populations
civiles le traitement loyal des
prisonniers de guerre le libre accès aux
organisations humanitaires
internationales et tout particulièrement
à la Croix Rouge le 2 novembre 2022 nous
avons auditionné celle que l'on appelle
les fans d'Azov dont les époux les
perles et fils ont défendu Mario Paul
jusqu'à la limite de leur force retenue
désormais dans des endroits tenus
secrets torturés privés de nourriture et
de soins ils sont sans contact avec leur
famille que cette résolution leur prouve
que nous ne les oublions pas et que nous
partageons les preuves de cette
inhumaine angoisse le 29 octobre 2022
nous recevions madame madvichu prix
Nobel de la Paix avocate qui dirige le
Centre pour les libertés civiles elle
recueille des témoignages pour
documenter les crimes de guerre on ne
documente pas seulement les violations
des Conventions de Genève
explique-t-elle en documente la
souffrance humaine chaque jour est lasse
elle entend le pire nous devons lui
promettre que ces dizaines de milliers
de récits ne seront ni vains ni perdu et
qu'un tribunal international dédié
rendra sa justice le 19 avril 2022 les
responsables de l'UNICEF témoignaient
des souffrances des enfants en temps de
guerre en Ukraine tout particulièrement
les enlèvements massifs d'enfants vers
la Russie déjà ne faisait plus de doute
même si leur décompte manque encore de
précision nous devons par cette
résolution les dénoncer vigoureusement à
cette occasion des chiffres nous ont été
rappelés en 1914 90% des victimes de la
guerre étaient militaire 10% étaient
civils de nos jours la proportion s'est
inversée et désormais dans un conflit où
l'un des deux belligérants cibles
intentionnellement les populations
civiles le nombre de femmes d'enfants et
de vieillards parmi les victimes est un
tolérable par cette résolution chers
collègues dénonçons une dérive inhumaine
je voudrais aussi avoir une pensée pour
nos collègues députés de la Rada
d'Ukraine qui travaille chaque jour et
sans relâche parfois sous les attaques
des bombes par exemple ou de milaboui
mystère qui au lendemain de l'agression
du 24 février témoignée par visio en
gilet par balle demander des casques et
supplier l'Europe de fermer le ciel
voici quelques-unes des voix que je
porte au nom du groupe d'amitié chaque
jour de guerre est un jour de trop à la
gare de Kiev un grand nombre de jeunes
gens chaque jour partent pour le front
et une file d'ambulance récupère les
blessés c'est d'une tristesse infinie
nous souhaitons tous que cette guerre
cessent au plus vite
et c'est aussi notre rôle et notre
devoir d'exiger tout de suite le respect
des valeurs essentielles de la France
pays des droits de l'homme enfin je dois
vous dire chers collègues au fil des
auditions mon oreille rusophone ce
familiarise avec le craignant un mot
revient dans chaque phrase et j'ai fini
par le comprendre petrimka petrinka le
soutien l'Ukraine a besoin de notre
soutien de notre soutien sans faille à
chaque instant le Président stefanchouk
nous a dit la semaine dernière la
culture japonais une année de notre vie
et bien mais vous avez aussi changé oui
nous avons changé nous avons appris le
sens du mot soutien je vous remercie
merci
alors la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis Masson pour 3 minutes chers
collègues je voterai contre ce projet de
résolution pour trois raisons
premièrement on organisant un blocus
économique contre la Russie et en
fournissant des armes ainsi qu'une aide
financière l'Ukraine les pays de l'Union
européenne et de l'OTAN sont devenus des
kobelligérants notre boycotte du gaz du
pétrole et des matières premières russes
est ainsi la cause de l'inflation et de
la crise économique que nous subissons
nous nous sommes donc pénalisés
nous-mêmes
deuxièmement on ne peut pas faire de
reproches à la Russie si dans le même
temps on laisse faire et même en
cautionne une agression encore plus
scandaleuse contre un autre pays or le
temps et l'Union européenne n'ont rien
fait lorsque l'Arménie a été attaquée
par les deux dictateurs d'Azerbaïdjan et
de Turquie pire on est même allé jusqu'à
doubler nos achats de produits
pétroliers à l'Azerbaïdjan ce qui ne
peut qu'encourager sa politique
d'agression
quant à la Turquie nous soutenons un
pays dont le dictateur se réjouit du 1er
génocide contre les Arméniens et qui a
actuellement une politique doublement
génocidaire d'une part contre lecture
contre les Kurdes et d'autre part contre
les Arméniens si c'était la Russie qui
avait attaqué l'Arménie l'OTAN et
l'Union européenne aurait réagi très
vieux heureusement c'est bien la preuve
que l'OTAN a des arrières pensées
[Applaudissements]
enfin troisièmement nous sommes
actuellement dans la même situation
qu'elle avait de la Première Guerre
mondiale
à l'époque l'Allemagne n'était pas la
seule responsable de cette guerre car
les pays de l'entendent soutenaient la
Serbie et les terroristes
serbobosniaques qui ont assassiné
l'archiduc d'Autriche aujourd'hui la
guerre en Ukraine est en apparence liée
à l'agression de la Russie mais elle
résulte aussi de l'extension vers l'est
de l'OTAN et de l'Union européenne ce
qui conduit à encercler littéralement la
Russie les États-Unis n'ont jamais
accepté que l'Union soviétique puisse
installer des fusées à Cuba pourquoi
voudrait-on que les Russes acceptent
aujourd'hui d'être encerclé par le temps
en voulant mettre la Russie à genoux le
temps prend le risque irresponsable d'un
conflit nucléaire
tout comme la première guerre mondiale
cela pourrait nous faire des dizaines de
millions de morts aussi bien d'un côté
que de l'autre ceci étant je suis je
compatis avec la situation aussi bien de
tous les Russes qui sont morts dans
cette guerre que de tous les Ukrainiens
mais je crois qu'il y a une lourde
responsabilité des pays occidentaux dans
cette affaire
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Jean-Claude Roquier pour le
groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et sociales européens pour
5 minutes chers collègues au président
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous sommes en quelques
jours dans la date tragique de
l'anniversaire de la question portée par
la Fédération de Russie contre l'Ukraine
cela fait allez c'est bientôt Alain
Vladimir Poutine
russe cela fait bientôt un an qui
replonge le monde dans les affres de la
guerre en faisant croire à qui veut
entendre qu'au fond c'est l'Occident de
l'agresseur face à cela depuis des mois
sans se résigner sans finir les
Ukrainiens restent debout
malgré la durée combat dans l'est de
l'Ukraine malgré le Deluxe des bombes
qui fravent la population civile du
soccer de Kiev les ukrainiens et le
président zeneski forcent le respect
le courage du peuple ukrainien n'est
plus démontré il a des horaires
d'exemple il s'écrira certainement dans
l'histoire Lucia
sont quelques individus de symboles
d'énergie ce sont aussi des villes
martyrs oui monsieur Stéphane souk l'a
rappelé lors des organes dans notre
hémicycle la semaine dernière je cite
l'ennemi cruel sève la mort à la
destruction les Ukrainiens pétrir le
prix de la liberté par conséquence de
continuer à les soutenir d'autant plus
que nous agissons aussi pour notre
propre sécurité celle de l'Europe élève
au-delà comme la triste
le président de la République de la
radar ukrainienne l'Ukraine est devenu
le bouclier qui protège l'Europe et
l'ensemble du monde civilisé c'est une
de ces évidence qui engage de plus en
plus fortement la France et la
communauté internationale
il ne s'agit plus seulement de la
souveraineté d'un territoire envahi mais
bien d'un combat il collectif pour
établir les règles élémentaires de
l'ordre mondial même Israël jusqu'à la
retrait interroge depuis quelques jours
sa position tant le macabre dcs
stratégique russe bouleverse tous les
équilibres stratégiques dans ces
conditions comme le souligne à
proposition de résolution l'aide fournit
à l'Ukraine doit être accentuée sur tous
les fronts le front des sanctions bien
entendu arrêt jouit de voir arriver un
dixième paquet de mesure annoncé par
Bruxelles
pourvu qu'elle a fait que
l'affaiblissent l'industrie des défenses
russes l'Union européenne doit toutefois
se pencher sur la question des
contournements qui affectent la réalité
d'une partie des sanctions quant au from
militaire
la nécessité d'un effort constant de
livraison d'armes forts ukrainiennes
apparaît désormais incontournable on
peut le regretter certains balles
d'escalade même versons pas les rôles
comme le sexy bien la propagande russe
jusque sur le continent africain qui a
gravé les marches de l'horreur sous
couvert d'une prétendue opération
spéciale à ce stade nous savons qu'une
clé d'indiquer la victoire ukrainienne
réside à la défense antérienne mon gros
battant de la France qui a contribue à
consolider à défenses solaires de
l'Ukraine en complément de soutien
militaire américain significatif bien
entendu nous souscrivons à la réserve
qui consiste à préserver le territoire
russe des attaques des missiles quant au
front diplomatique doit-on y croire
encore nous avons espéré jusqu'à la
veille du 24 février 2022 en novembre
aujourd'hui hélas les dénégociations de
paix semblent ne semble pas le
visageable allez-y déçu pour ne pas dire
humilier par son insuciaire
dans une spirale paranoïaque Vladimir le
redoutable continue d'organiser son
armée dans une logique de guerre un
changement général le développement du
LA MONDIALE mobilisation et une quasi
installation dans son pays d'un pouvoir
parallèle représenté par la ministre
prix gauche s'agissant de ces
mercenaires mon groupe souscrit à lié de
cibler Wagner
leur brutalité et sans équivoque et on
doit par ailleurs s'inquiéter
de la développement sur le continent
africain chers
de Malleret les membres du ADSL à votre
en toute logique nous espérons apporter
notre modeste contribution au combat du
monde de libre
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal Alizard
pour le groupe les républicains pour 12
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
sur un sujet à faire étrangères et avant
de vous parler de l'Ukraine je voudrais
que nous ayons une pensée forte et aussi
exprimée notre solidarité notre soutien
aux populations syriennes et turques
victimes du séisme de ce weekend
depuis un an l'actualité internationale
est dominée par cette guerre en Ukraine
à l'initiative de la Russie Russie
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies membres de l'OSCE et
du Conseil de l'Europe notamment autant
dire que la Russie n'ignore rien des
principes du droit international et
pourtant les autoris les autorités
russes n'ont pas hésité à déclencher une
violente opération militaire contre un
État souverain l'Ukraine baptisé
pudiquement opération spéciale elle est
en fait une vraie guerre d'invasion
visant à la conquête de territoire au
remplacement d'autorité légale
démocratiquement élue à la mise au pas
du peuple ukrainien et à la main mise
sur l'économie et l'agriculture ce coût
de force illégal nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter ce serait la fin de l'ordre
national et le retour à la loi du plus
fort dans ce contexte l'initiative de
notre collègue Claude Malhuret est à
saluer et s'adresse un message fort et
clair du Sénat nous avons d'ailleurs
reçu si même il y a quelques jours une
importante d'élégation ukrainienne
conduite par le président de la Rada
précédé d'ailleurs par un entretien avec
le ministre de la Défense
ukrainien quel que soit les causes
invoquées par les autorités russes à la
pluie de leur politique belliqueuse il
reste que dans ce conflit il y a tout de
même un agresseur et un agressé
l'Ukraine est un État souverain dont
l'intégrité territoriale doit être
respectée et les règles du droit
international ont été volontairement
ignorés par la Russie
ce conflit brutal décime les civils
Ukrainiens détruit des installations
vitales rasent des villes et aboutit à
l'occupation illégale de territoires
pire encore une partie des opérations et
sous-traitée à des mercenaires recrutés
dans des prisons russes ainsi qu'à des
forces tchétchen dont les méthodes sont
destinées à terroriser en déplacement en
Ukraine avec le président Larcher et
quelques collègues nous avons vu in situ
cette sale guerre dans laquelle les
exactions sont commises quotidiennement
contre des civils sans compter les
missiles qui cible les habitations des
contes devront être rendus par les
responsables de ces actions criminelles
contraires à toutes les lois y compris
contraire aux lois de la guerre c'est le
sens de cette proposition de résolution
le conflit à raviver la peur sur le
continent européen qui après deux
guerres mondiales se croyaient à l'abri
la bulle de prospérité économique
l'économie européenne est désormais
victime des effets collatéraux de cette
guerre est fait collatéraux qui
s'étendent jusqu'à la rive sud de la
Méditerranée et même au-delà l'Europe a
aussi dû faire face à un flot historique
de réfugiés ainsi je le crois les
Européens ont eu tort de considérer les
questions stratégiques comme secondaire
quand d'autres États renforcés leurs
outils de puissance et diversifiés leur
mode d'action les inquiétudes les plus
fortes s'expriment chez les voisins
immédiats de la Russie ou la confiance
vous le savez n'a jamais véritablement
régner ce fut la neutralité contrainte
de la Finlande également le rideau de
fer qui ajouta l'Europe qui a amputa
pardon l'Europe et son flan est un
certain nombre de pays traumatisés par
cette expérience ont souhaité rejoindre
l'Union européenne et le temps
les vagues successives d'élargissement
ont porté l'Union européenne et l'OTAN
aux frontières russes avec des
conséquences géopolitiques peut être mal
anticipées même n'y est parfois par
certains il s'agissait en effet de
l'adhésion à un projet politique et
économique européen d'un côté et à une
alliance militaire menée par les
États-Unis de l'eau cette
occidentalisation rapide de territoire
longtemps liés à la Russie leur passage
sous protection américaine n'est pas un
changement anodin mais à l'époque on
croyait fermement peut-être à tort à la
fin de l'histoire entre guillemets et à
l'affaiblissement durable de la Russie
la politique européenne de partenariats
oriental conçu au départ comme la
création d'un cercle d'amis je cite est
devenu plus ambigu pour les Russes
l'Union européenne travaille dans leur
arrière-cour pour l'Union européenne au
contraire les pays du Partenariat
oriental sont des pays souverains c'est
exact et qui compare librement les
offres et leur liberté de choix doit
être respectée au final le projet
d'accord entre l'Union européenne et
l'Ukraine les velléités ukrainiennes
d'adhérer à l'OTAN ont donné lieu à la
réactivation de tension avec la Russie
et à l'enchaînement de fait tragique au
cours de cette période je crois que les
Occidentaux ont peut-être mal
appréhendés les ressorts du
fonctionnement russe d'abord le puissant
complexe obsidional historique qui
aujourd'hui tourne à l'obsession voire à
la paranoïa surtout pour des dirigeants
formés dans l'appareil sécuritaire
soviétique
tout le narratif russe s'appuie sur ce
sentiment d'encerclement de
marginalisation qui justifie les
investissements massifs dans le domaine
de la défense les actions militaires à
l'extérieur de plus les Russes sont le
sentiment avec les largissements
successifs d'un abus de faiblesse commis
au moment où leur pays était au plus bas
alors aujourd'hui ou allons-nous quels
sont nos objectifs et des l'Ukraine à se
défendre récupérer la Crimée changer le
régime à Moscou ces objectifs sont-ils
partagés par tous les soutiens à
l'Ukraine et en mesure-t-on bien toutes
les conséquences toutes ces questions
mériteraient une réponse claire des
autorités françaises et européennes car
l'émotion si légitime soit-elle ne peut
pas et ne peut en aucun cas être notre
boussole beaucoup de choses ont été
faites en matière de dénonciation de la
Russie de sanctions et d'aide à
l'Ukraine un nouveau paquet de sanctions
contre étant préparation c'est une bonne
chose nous avons aussi livré des
équipements individuels des munitions du
renseignement du matériel de guerre tels
que des systèmes d'artillerie le débat
récent porte sur l'envoi de char légers
ou lourd en quelle quantité cette
évolution doctrinale comporte nombre de
difficultés d'ordre stratégiques
opérationnelle et politique et déjà les
autorités ukrainiennes réclament des
avions on peut le comprendre le
président Macron a annonce que rien
n'est interdit par principe on peut
l'entendre aussi mais c'est une telle
montée en puissance se confirmer il
serait de plus en plus délicat de se
déclarer extérieur au conflit et à être
considéré comme tel il faut bien le
mesurer malgré ces mesures et les
dernières annonces nous ne voyons pas
d'inflexion des autorités russes au
contraire nous assistons à une
radicalisation des discours à
l'émergence sur la scène politique de
personnages inquiétants
il l'a fait durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ou plus récemment en
Tchétchénie le pouvoir russe mise sur le
stock sur le temps long pardon dans une
guerre de saturation une guerre
d'attrition grâce aux immenses stocks
accumulées et au peu de café des vies de
ces soldats surtout lorsqu'ils viennent
des confins de la fédération et enfin
l'économie russe résiste au FMI et ce
même effet mi prévoit pour 2024 une
croissance pour la Russie supérieure à
celle de la zone euro comprennent qui
pourra nos sanctions et nos moyens
militaires contingentés même
technologiquement supérieur
suffiront-ils à changer la donne
jusqu'où sommes-nous prêts à aller face
à une puissance dotée nous sommes
désormais sur un terrain glissant les
opinions publiques commencent à
s'interroger y compris aux États-Unis la
question du contrôle des armes livrées
et du bon usage des aides est aussi un
projet majeur par ailleurs cette
situation malheureusement fait le jeu de
la Chine et des États-Unis je constate
aujourd'hui combien il est judicieux
pour les Chinois d'avoir mis en place
des outils financiers alternatifs
permettant d'échapper aux sanctions
occidentales et qui peuvent être
proposés à leurs alliés comme la Russie
de plus les entreprises russes se
tournent vers le van pour leur contrat
et cette pratique pourrait durablement
sans créer en janvier 2023 la Russie
annonçait que la relance du marché des
changes allait permettre de privilégier
le One pour se désolariser je cite ces
rapprochements Russo chinois dans de
nombreux domaines doivent donc là aussi
nous interpeller l'Europe pourrait se
trouver cornerisée dans deux grands axes
Chine Russie d'une part et États-Unis et
leurs alliés anglo-saxons d'autre part
la Chine se garde bien de soutenir
ouvertement l'invasion russe sans pour
autant la désavouer non plus et déjà à
travers ce conflit et la politique de
sanctions qui en découle la division du
monde prend corps entre le camp
occidental et le reste du monde autour
d'un pôle Russo chinois tandis que l'ONU
est de plus en plus marginalisé en
raison des sanctions les difficultés
financières de la Russie ces besoins en
bien équipement haute technologie la
rapproche encore plus de la Chine quant
aux États-Unis après la période de Trump
assez désastreuse pour leur image
internationale l'évacuation difficile
non concertées de Kaboul ils ont amorcé
un réengagement en Europe malgré la
primauté accordée à la zone
Indo-Pacifique la faveur de la guerre en
Ukraine dans toute l'Europe les achats
sur étagères de matériel américain se
multiplient à l'avenir à la ferme
l'avenir de la bit2 européenne et
notamment française est en jeu si les
Européens a juste titre ont montré une
certaine unité une vraie fermeté la
Russie je ne suis pas sûr à ce stade
qu'ils aient gagné en crédibilité dans
la mesure où la plupart d'entre eux
considèrent que seul l'OTAN et les
États-Unis sont en capacité de les
protéger l'Europe puissance est encore
loin et Washington n'a aucun intérêt à
une trop grande autonomie politique et
militaire européenne alors pour la
France le chemin de crête est étroit
tout en gardant ouvert les canaux de
dialogue il semble important de
maintenir une ligne de fermeté vis-à-vis
de l'agresseur russe de poursuivre le
soutien au peuple
ukrainien mais également de porter une
attention plus soutenue aux actions
indirectes menées par la Russie en
Afrique francophone et dont nous sommes
la cible le moment venu il faudra aussi
aider en lien avec nos partenaires à la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine au réforme
nécessaire notamment en matière d'état
de droit et de lutte la corruption est
aussi économie nous voterons donc cette
proposition je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
l'apocadie pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues voilà près
d'un an la Fédération de Russie a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine mes premiers mots
seront pour la population
ukrainienne et sa résistance admirable
face à la barbarie de l'envahisseur
l'occasion nous est donnée avec cette
résolution transpartisane du président
maluré de réaffirmer le soutien du Sénat
envers l'Ukraine une semaine après avoir
ovationné ici le président de la Rada
ukrainienne
Anne de Kiev reine des Francs il y a
près de 1000 ans aurait toute sa place
parmi les femmes illustres qui ornent le
jardin du Luxembourg en érigeant sa
statue le Sénat pourrait rappeler ainsi
les liens indissolubles qui unissent
l'Ukraine à la France
ce soutien à l'Ukraine nous avions voulu
la porter avec le président malloret en
nous rendant à Kiev le 20 avril dernier
quelques jours après que les Russes
soient chassés de ses environs à irpin
Boro dionka bout decha ville martyrs ont
commis des massacres nous avions
découvert un cadre indescriptible de
ruines ou même les statues avaient reçu
une balle dans la tête
à bout de chat avec des enfants nous
avions planté des arbres pour rappeler
que l'espérance le bien et nos valeurs
l'emporteront au final
ses enfants Ukrainiens connaissent
désormais les abris la terreur des
bombardements
leur regard vide et triste me hante je
suis revenu du crâne avec la conviction
que tout doit être entrepris pour
arrêter cette guerre en détruisant les
infrastructures énergétiques de
nombreuses villes l'armée russe utilise
l'hiver et le froid comme une arme pour
faire céder la population les frappes
incessantes sur les immeubles les
hôpitaux ou encore les écoles et les
crèches constituent une véritable
stratégie de la terreur à l'encontre des
Ukrainiens nous déplorons des dizaines
de milliers de civils morts ou blessés
la cruauté de Monsieur Poutine peine à
trouver ses limites un crime impuni est
un crime récompensé selon la formule de
mélèm Khalaf un député libanais qui
occupe son parlement depuis 20 jours
aujourd'hui avec sa collègue Najat
Saliba afin d'exiger l'élection du
président libanais que prévoit le
gouvernement et l'Union européenne pour
que les crimes de guerre et les crimes
contre l'humanité commis par la
Fédération de Russie soit jugée et leurs
auteurs punis depuis un an la France se
tient aux côtés de l'Ukraine avec ses
partenaires européens dès le début du
conflit des trains de sanctions étaient
décidés
à faire la guerre à ce jour l'Union
européenne a décidé de neuf-35ions
intégrant également la Biélorussie et
l'Iran pour l'aide qu'ils apportent à la
Russie ce dont nous félicitons fidèle à
sa devise unie dans la diversité l'Union
européenne a démontré la volonté d'agir
ensemble pour relever les défis la
Pologne a affirmé un rôle de leadership
avec les États baltes et la Roumanie
pour mobiliser l'Union européenne et ne
pas tergiverser
l'aide de l'Union européenne que ce soit
en matière de protection civile par son
soutien force armé ukrainienne a
contribué à soutenir la résistance
héroïque du peuple ukrainien face à son
envahisseur soyons en fiers nous pouvons
également participer à la reconstruction
économique ukrainienne en facilitant le
retour des investisseurs il faudrait
pour cela Monsieur le Ministre changer
la couleur rouge à l'ouest du pays de la
carte conseil en voyageur
pour accompagner la l'Ukraine dans sa
lutte pour sa liberté et sa défense et
la défense de nos valeurs nous devons
aller plus loin dans nos livraisons
d'armes le président annonçait vouloir
aider à renforcer les systèmes
anti-aériens en Ukraine pouvez-vous nous
préciser si le sujet a été évoqué lors
du sommet Union européenne
Ukraine le 3 février dernier comme vous
l'aurez compris le groupe Union
centriste votre a pour cette résolution
je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier bèche
un ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs la
proposition de résolution aujourd'hui
débattue de votre assemblée porte sur un
enjeu particulièrement important pour la
France et pour l'avenir du continent
européen l'agression russe de l'Ukraine
déclenché le 24 février peu après 8 ans
de conflits larvé et d'ingérence
militaire russe en Ukraine a vu le
retour de la guerre interétatique de
haute intensité en Europe impliquant un
état doté de l'arme nucléaire
par cet acte d'une extrême gravité la
Russie affranchi toutes les limites et
violer les règles régissant les
relations internationales depuis 1945
notamment les principes fondateurs de la
Charte des Nations Unies que sont la
souveraineté des États et le respect de
leur intégrité territoriale c'est
invasion les objectifs mis en avant pour
Moscou pour justifier sa prétendue
opération militaire spéciale et
l'annexion illégale de quatre régions
ukrainiennes à l'issue de simulacre de
référendum démontre si besoin était la
volonté russe de nier l'existence de
l'Ukraine en tant que nation
indépendante est libre de choisir son
destin
alors que nous approchons du premier
anniversaire de cette agression barbare
injustifiée et à justifiable force est
de constater que la Russie n'a en rien
abandonné ses objectifs et qu'elle
cherche à soumettre la nation
ukrainienne par la force militaire
malgré les revers sérieux qu'elle a
connu retrait de la région de craie de
Kiev au printemps dernier
contre-offensive
ukrainienne réussie dans la région de
kerkiff en septembre abandon de Kerson
en novembre seul Capital régional
qu'elle avait conquise et prétendait à
avoir annexé la Russie poursuit son
agression avec une violence sans limite
elle exerce aujourd'hui une pression
extrême dans le don-basse ou elle a
réussi à progresser dans le secteur de
backmouth sans la moindre considération
pour ses propres soldats qu'elle utilise
comme de la chair à canon
seule la Russie est responsable de la
poursuite des hostilités en Ukraine
alors que l'Ukraine a montré sa
disponibilité à travailler à une paix
juste et durable à travers le plan de
paix en 10 points présenté par le
président les zonaski que la France
soutient
la Russie poursuit par ailleurs sa
stratégie lâche et cynique visant à
détruire les infrastructures
essentielles de l'Ukraine afin de mettre
le pays à genoux depuis le début du mois
d'octobre des salves successives de
missiles et de drones vise les
infrastructures électriques gazières ou
de distribution d'eau nécessaire à la
survie de la population civile pendant
l'hiver la dernière salle a eu lieu le
26 janvier le jour où la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine colonnat visiter la
ville de dessin qui a été touchée
l'objectif russe est clair
désorganiser l'arrière ukrainien et
semer la terreur parmi la population
pour infléchir la résistance de
l'Ukraine à l'agression ce ciblage
systématique de la population civile la
ministre l'a rappelé cela ne s'apparente
pas à faire la guerre
c'est faire des crimes de guerre dans
ces circonstances la résistance dont
font preuve depuis près d'une année
l'armée et la population ukrainienne
force notre admiration
en conjuguant la bravoure et la
détermination de ces soldats aux
équipements sophistiqués que nous lui
avons livré l'Ukraine a montré qu'elle
était capable de résister et de
repousser l'envahisseur russe nous le
redisons la Russie ne parviendra pas à
briser la résistance du peuple ukrainien
celui-ci se bat pour sa liberté et dans
cette lutte l'Ukraine n'est pas seule
nous nous tenons à ses côtés et nous
continuerons de le faire pour l'aider à
retrouver son intégrité territoriale et
sa souveraineté c'est ce message de
soutien indéfectible qu'apportait aux
autorités ukrainiennes la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Madame Catherine Colonna lors de sa
visite à Odessa le 26 janvier c'est ce
même message que le Président de la
République a transmis au président de la
Rada et au ministre ukrainien de la
défense la semaine dernière
dès le début de cette agression que nous
avons cherché à éviter jusqu'au
dernières heures la France s'est placée
du côté du respect du droit et de la
liberté en apportant son plein soutien à
l'Ukraine dans l'exercice de sa légitime
défense
ce conflit nous le savons ne se règlera
pas intégralement par les armes il
faudra à un moment se mettre autour de
la table et négocier mais ce moment
n'est pas venu et ce sera à l'Ukraine et
à l'Ukraine seul de décider quand et à
quel condition elle souhaitera le faire
nous avons donc consenti un effort
considérable de livraison et
d'équipements militaires et nous
continuerons de le faire afin de mettre
l'Ukraine en position de force pour
recouvrer son intégrité territoriale la
décision du Président de la République
de livrer des chars légers début janvier
à initier une dynamique positive parmi
nos partenaires et ouvert la voie la
livraison de matériels cruciaux pour les
forces armées ukrainiennes
de nouvelles annonces françaises ont été
faites par le Président de la République
et le ministre des armées à l'occasion
de la visite du ministre ukrainien de la
Défense à Paris le 31 janvier nous
allons fournir à l'Ukraine 12 canons
César qui s'ajouteront au 18 déjà
fournis nous allons poursuivre notre
soutien dans le domaine entière
fournitures d'une batterie
asmpt conjointement avec l'Italie d'un
radar GM20 et de missiles pour les
batteries anti-aériennes crottes
essentiel pour protéger la population
civile ukrainienne des frappes russes
nous travaillons également à des
solutions pour fournir à l'Ukraine des
munitions de nouveaux véhicules blindés
du carburant et pour assurer le maintien
en conditions opérationnelles des
équipements livrés et assurer un
ravitaillement en carburant
nous avons participé au lancement de la
mission militaire européenne eux-mêmes
et le ministre Sébastien Lecornu a
annoncé que nous formerions 2000 soldats
Ukrainiens sur le territoire français
d'ici l'été tandis que 150 militaires
français se rendront à la fin du mois en
Pologne pour former jusqu'à 600 soldats
Ukrainiens par mois nous sommes
également l'un des plus importants
contributeurs à la facilité européenne
de paix qui apporte un soutien en
équipement militaire létal inédit au
niveau européen et nous avons mis en
place un fond bilatéral que vous avez
porté à 200 millions d'euros pour que
l'Ukraine puisse se fournir en matériel
auprès de notre base industrielle et de
technologie de défense
la France est donc comme les Ukrainiens
le disent même un soutien de premier
plan à la fois par l'ampleur des
montants mobilisés par la fiabilité du
matériel qui a fourni et par l’arabilité
avec laquelle elle parvient à répondre
aux besoins exprimés par pièce
mais notre aide ne se limite évidemment
pas au domaine militaire nous consacrons
au total plus de 2 milliards d'euros à
l'aide civile à l'Ukraine face aux
conséquences humanitaires dramatiques
des frappes russes contre les
infrastructures ukrainiennes nous avons
organisé le 13 décembre à Paris la
conférence solidaire du peuple ukrainien
afin d'aider l'Ukraine à passer l'hiver
47 états et 24 organisations
internationales auront pour du présent
et ont promis plus d'un milliard d'euros
d'aide d'urgence qu'il s'agisse de dons
matériels ou de financement dans les
domaines de l'énergie de l'eau de la
santé de l'alimentation et des
transports la France a pour sa part
annoncé un effort total de 125 millions
d'euros pour les seuls mois de l'hiver
l'intégralité de cette somme aura été
engagée au 15 février ce qui correspond
rapporté à la fenêtre calendaire à
l'effort humanitaire le plus important
jamais déployé par notre pays
aura un impact concret sur la vie de
milliers d'ukrainien victimes de la
stratégie russe visant à faire de
l'hiver une arme de guerre pour vous
donner des exemples concrets 63
générateurs haute puissance sont en
train d'être livrés en Ukraine en plus
des 100 déjà livrés début décembre ainsi
que 5 millions d'ampoules LED qui
permettront de réaliser d'importantes
économiques d'énergie
l'effort total dans le secteur
humanitaire s'élève à 200 millions
d'euros en faveur de l'Ukraine et des
pays limitrophes notre centre de crise
et de soutien à mener plus de 40
opérations pour un total de 2700 tonnes
d'aide acheminées
nous avons également apporté un soutien
précieux aux juridictions ukrainienne et
internationales en matière de lutte
contre l'impunité c'est l'une de nos
priorités car il n'y aura pas de paix
durable en Ukraine sans justice nous
avons apporté un soutien aux enquêtes
ukrainiennes de la CPI et de regius afin
de contribuer à la collecte des preuves
de crimes de guerre nous avons aussi
envoyé deux équipes de médecins légistes
et de gendarmes de l'IRCGN à bousta en
avril et dans la région de kerki fin
septembre et fait don de deux
laboratoires d'analyses ADN nous
participons aux réflexion sur la
poursuite du crime d'agression qui a
initié l'Ukraine dans le cadre du col
groupe qui s'est réuni à Prague les 26
et 27 janvier dernier et nous
accueillerons la prochaine réunion de ce
groupe à Strasbourg fin mars
nous sommes aussi mobilisés pour
apporter une aide financière à l'Ukraine
à titre bilatéral et au niveau européen
et participer à l'effort de
reconstruction à plus long terme qui se
structure sous l'égide de la plateforme
de coordination des donateurs mise en
place à Bruxelles par le G7 parmi nos 2
milliards d'euros d'aide nous avons
octroyé un pré budgétaire direct de 400
millions violet FD et fléchir 1,2
milliards vers des garanties à l'export
qui bénéficie à de larges spectre de
projet économiques essentiel à la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine un exemple
concret celui de la plateforme numérique
de la modélisation de la reconstruction
de l'aublast de tchernilif porté par
trois entreprises françaises
enfin nous poursuivons nos efforts
visant accroître les difficultés de la
Russie à financer sa guerre d'agression
par l'adoption de nouvelles sanctions
celles-ci sont une preuve de l'unité
européenne les États membres ont réagi
avec une rapidité sans précédent en
adoptant les premières mesures 40 heures
après l'invasion russe nous avons depuis
lors adopté 9 paquets de sanctions
sectorielles comme individuels au niveau
européen mais aussi bâti des coalitions
avec nos partenaires du G7 et
l'Australie afin de plafonner le prix du
pétrole russe ces sanctions ciblées et
proportionnées portent leurs fruits
comme en atteste la baisse du prix du
pétrole brut russe depuis la mise en
œuvre
de ce dispositif de plafonnement dans la
perspective de l'adoption d'un dixième
paquet de sanctions dans les prochaines
semaines la France prépare de nouvelles
initiatives visant à entraver le
fonctionnement de l'économie de guerre
russe et à sanctionner ses responsables
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
vous le voyez le soutien de la France
est total il engage l'ensemble de l'État
français mais mobilise au-delà des
collectivités les ONG les entreprises et
je le sais parfaitement votre hôte
assemblée le soutien que nous apportons
à l'Ukraine c'est notre devoir
c'est notre honneur et ce sont
évidemment nos valeurs les valeurs d'une
république qui s'est bâtissent sur la
défense du droit et de ses libertés le
vote de la proposition de résolution
aujourd'hui soumis à votre examen le
confirmera j'en suis persuadé ensemble
nous nous tenons debout sans faiblir aux
côtés de l'Ukraine et nous continuerons
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra à le
faire je vous remercie
merci Monsieur mimi femme alors nous
allons procéder au vote sur la
proposition de résolution la Conférence
des Présidents a décidé que les
interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe Les Indépendants il doit être
procédé au scrutin public d'un condition
fixé par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert nombre de votants
donc 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
340 pour l'adoption 324 contre 16 le
Sénat a adopté
vous l'avez vu le Sénat a adopté une
proposition de résolution visant à
montrer le soutien de la chambre haute à
l'Ukraine et à appeler au renforcement
de l'aide fournie 324 voix pour et 16
voix contre dont celle du groupe
communiste qui craint une escalade qui
entraînerait la France dans un conflit
mondial 100% Sénat c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui quant à moi je vous souhaite
une très belle journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure c'est l'émission qui
rend les co-responsables cette semaine
zoom sur l'un des secteurs les plus
polluants de notre économie la mode et
pour la rendre plus durable un nouvel
étiquetage comprenant des informations
sur la provenance des vêtements est
obligatoire depuis le 1er janvier alors
cela permettra-t-il de rendre les
marques plus vertueuses les
consommateurs sont-ils prêts à jouer le
jeu malgré un engouement toujours plus
grand pour la fast fashion les marques
sont-elles prêtes à entamer leur
révolution verte réponse cette semaine
dans pQCD pourvu que ça dure samedi à
18h30 sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les passagers direction la Guadeloupe à
6800 km de Paris dans la commune de
Bouillante voici la nouvelle génération
de déchetterie celle-là date de 2021
Kevin Absalon est l'un des ingénieurs à
l'origine du projet donc ici on retrouve
micro-onde ventilateur
cette zone c'est le gros électroménager
mobilier ferraille déchets verts ici on
peut tout trier il suffit de venir en
voiture se garer et déposer les déchets
dans la benne dans la base terre il y
avait seulement trois déchetteries pour
150 000 habitants il y en aura 7 de plus
dans les années à venir
voilà
comme ça au moins on peut tout trier
c'est très bien la façon que si
maintenant il y a pas de mouche il y a
rien ouais c'est plus c'est plus saine
ça nous préserve notre environnement et
le cadre est toujours agréable sur cette
île que tout le monde veut préserver ces
nouvelles déchettrices sont très
attendues elle permettront de diminuer
les quantités de déchets enfoui et de
faire disparaître les décharges sauvages
on en trouve au bord des champs au pied
des immeubles comme cet amas de
ferraille et d'appareils électroménagers
il y en a de moins en moins au fur et à
mesure que les déchetteries se
construisent sur les territoires qui a
un vrai mariage sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la Basse-Terre on retrouve
de moins en moins ce type de déchets et
l'objectif c'est qu'il n'est plus voilà
dans ces nouvelles déchetteries en
partie financée par l'ADEME et l'Europe
on voit même plus loin que le recyclage
en favorisant le réemploi cette pièce
aménagée au cœur de la déchetterie est
une donnerie il y a des vêtements pour
enfants des vêtements pour adultes
on trouve également dans cette donnée
des bouquins les habitants déposent des
objets d'autres personnes et même des
associations peuvent les récupérer
il faut qu'on arrive
de plus en plus à ce à cela une seconde
vie un réemploi parce que nos ressources
ne sont pas infinies et partant de ce
principe et bien devrait plus rien jeter
en fait et on devrait arriver à 100% de
recyclage l'ensemble des déchets est
traité par des entreprises locales ou
envoyées en métropole l'objectif est de
valoriser 73% des déchets non dangereux
et non inertes en 2032
[Musique]
pendant des années on a parlé d'une
bombe à retardement et bien là la bombe
va péter en fait c'est 20 dernières
années l'immigration a fait exploser la
démographie de Lille la délinquance
explose les élus nous ont abandonné ça
devient intenable il y a plus de 50 % de
la population à Mayotte qui est en
situation irrégulaire et qui s'y confort
aujourd'hui on a passé le point de
non-retour Mayotte au bord de
l'explosion samedi à 18h sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sensublique votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes et
deux grands thèmes notre promesse et de
donner du temps à nos experts pour
donner du sens à l'actualité voici le
sommaire de ce